The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Well
welcome everybody.
I think most of the people
here in this class--
the presentations in this hour
are teams Kate, Don, and Chris.
So team Don, in
particular, if you
want to make sure you're
cued up and ready to go,
that would be great.
The presentations are
nine minutes in length.
We will have a hard
stop at nine minutes.
I have some signs
that we'll show,
and why don't we get to it.
We have three
presentations in this hour.
We should introduce the
panelists quickly as well.
Julie, do you want to start?
And then maybe Rob as well.
A quick introduction,
that'd be great.
JULIE GREENBERG: Sure.
I'm Julie Greenberg.
I work for MIT through
the Institute of Medical
Engineering and Science and the
Programming, Health Sciences
and Technology.
And I'm excited to see
these presentations.
ROB MILLER: I'm Rob Miller.
I'm a professor of
computer science here,
and I'm one of the [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
Team Kate, take it away.
PHILLIP ABEL: Hello everyone.
We are Team Kate.
My name is Philip Abel.
And with me here is
Raquel, Jenny, and Dhruv.
Today we're going to talk
about the project we worked
on all semester, particularly
on the different prototypes
that we created for different
cochlear implants [INAUDIBLE]
that we created over the
course of the semester.
The design process
that we went through,
the experiments that we
ran, and the results we got,
and what we learnt
from the process.
So let's talk
about client, Kate.
Kate works at a Cambridge
Disability Center,
which means she is particularly
concerned with ensuring
that homeowners in
the Cambridge area
follow the guidelines
that ensure that people
with special needs can access
buildings, in the Cambridge
area specifically.
So that's just an example of
one of the things she does.
And in addition to that, she
has a profound hearing loss
and wears cochlear implants.
There are two main
problems with this
that Kate wants-- at the
beginning of the semester, two
main problems that Kate
wanted us to address
were the issue that her
cochlear implants weren't
water-resistant, and
then, in addition to that,
the implants-- she wasn't
able to properly distinguish
between noise from behind her
or when someone was speaking
in front of her whenever she
was in a noisy settings--
in a noisy setting, sorry.
So it was this problem
that we decided to tackle.
And for this, we came
up with a HAAT context,
which was to create cochlear
implants attachments
that provide water-resistance
and then also enable
sound blocking.
So the idea of having
water-resistance
was to have something that would
help Kate be able to go out
whenever-- let's say in seasons
when it rains more often,
she would be able
to go out and not
have to worry about whether her
implants are going to get wet
or not.
And then in addition
to that, we decided--
we also thought
about making covers
that would enable her to
hear more clearly whenever
she is in a noisy sitting.
In particular, she would
be able to distinguish
between the sound that's
coming in front of her
from the one behind her.
Then, in addition to
that, we didn't really
tackle the problem
of attachment,
but it was just one
main idea that we
tried to integrate into
all the different covers
that we made, to ensure that
whenever she attached it
on her ear, it's
wouldn't fall off.
So over the course
of the semester,
we brainstormed
different prototypes.
At first, we began
with this idea
of creating one
compact cover that
would have all the
functionality she wanted.
For example, a cover that would
be water-resistant in addition
to blocking sound.
But when we spoke with Kate
during the iterative design
process, Kate told us she would
want a more modular design.
So we decided to go
with a modular approach.
So Raquel will take
it over from here.
RAQUEL: OK, so I'm
going to talk now
about the process of
creating our prototypes.
So here you see version
one of our prototype.
So what we used
originally was just plain
Instamorph, which
is plastic pellets
that you can melt down and
form into solid plastic.
So if you see in
the top left here,
those were our original
ideas for the rain cover.
So something to cover the
ear piece of the cochlear
implant, and then something
to cover the coil piece, which
is the flat, disk-like piece.
And then on the right
here were our ideas
for the sound
blocking attachments.
So we had this idea
to just slip something
onto the implant itself.
If you look at
the picture above,
the microphone is
actually located right
on the very top of that curve.
So that's why we're creating
these pieces-- to basically
fit right there
on the top, where
the microphone is located.
We also dabbled a
little bit in trying
to create some things out
of silicone and clear resin
and didn't have much
success on that,
but it was part of the process.
So these are v2 prototypes.
So we started to try
and think about how
we can make these more
aesthetically pleasing.
We tried to start incorporating
color into the Instamorph,
incorporating a little hood
for the cord that comes out
of the implant and
also incorporating
a back layer to the rain cover.
So here you see a plastic sheet
to provide water resistance
on the back side of
the cover as well.
And then here is
the next version
of the sound-blocking
prototype, which
we made of Sugru, which
we found we could just
make look a lot nicer and
smoother than with Instamorph.
So then onto our
final prototypes--
it's kind of the next round.
So on the left is a new
version of the sound-blocking
with Sugru, but with
a lot less Sugru,
so it's a lot less heavier.
And then we incorporated
Dycem, which
is a material that
provides grip,
because we were having an
issue with it falling off
of the implant.
The middle part
is the coil cover.
So we did end up using black
Instamorph with the back cover.
I'll just say really
quickly, and then a vinyl
cover for the water cover.
Final prototypes two-- so we
are moving forward with the ear
cover, with 3D printing.
So these are our
first prints of that.
And we're working with
Danger!Awesome to make these
look a little nicer and
continue on with that.
DHRUV: So in order to determine
the [INAUDIBLE] prototype,
we performed two
sets of experiments.
So one is the
sound-blocking experiment,
and the other was the
water-resistance task.
So in the sound-blocking
experiment,
we actually divided
it into two parts.
One was the
quantitative estimation,
where we wanted to quantify
how well our cover actually
blocked sound from behind and
enhanced sound from the front.
The other was the
qualitative analysis.
And we wanted to [? value if ?]
the cover actually
caused increased
comprehension for Kate or not.
And the other type was
the water resistant touch.
And the goal was to
restrict the amount of water
that goes into the implant.
So the sound-blocking
experiment,
we asked Kate to touch in the
center of the [INAUDIBLE] table
in one of the quiet classrooms
of the [INAUDIBLE] department.
We placed the laptop at
various angles around Kate,
and placed at different
frequencies and intensities.
For each angle, and
for each intensity,
we wanted to determine the
minimal threshold at which Kate
is able to hear the sound.
This experiment was performed
both with and without
the cover.
On the right, you can
see the comparison
of the result for both with
and without the cover--
had a frequency of 1000Hz.
As you can see, the
listening of [INAUDIBLE]
and in the field
of view of Kate,
and with the [? anterior ?]
views behind Kate.
JENNY: For the water resistance
testing, we did two tests.
One was this water bead
test where we put water
on top of the cover to just
measure whether the cover was
actually waterproof or not, and
we put the implant, and then
a paper towel, and
then the cover on top
and let the water sit for both
10 seconds and then 10 minutes
and then checked to see if there
was any wetness underneath that
seeped onto the paper towel.
There ended up not being any
witness on the water bead test
and-- for the water bead
test and the rain test.
And the rain test was
just another one where
it is a little more realistic.
We placed the implant
on a vertical surface
with the coil cover as well
and then splashed water on it
as if it were
raining, and we also
found that there was
no wetness either.
So for the subjective
results-- this
is, I guess, another term
for Kate's feedback--
she provided very good
feedback from the beginning.
She was really involved
with our design process,
and these are a couple quotes
that we pulled from the most
recent feedback she gave us
on the sound blocking covers,
and we actually tested them out
at a restaurant-- using them
at a restaurant in
a noisy environment,
just to find a realistic
setting and found
that the designs worked well.
PROFESSOR: In another
30 seconds or so,
you should probably wrap up.
JENNY: That's perfect, because
this is the last slide.
So a few things we
learned-- our project was
kind of this
assistive technology
that we were augmenting onto
Kate's assistive technology,
her cochlear implants.
And that was interesting for
us to learn that-- of course,
assistive technology is
supposed to help someone
with their disability, but
it's, of course, not perfect,
and we had to patch it to
make it even better and more
useful for Kate.
Throughout the design process
we explored a lot of options,
and we felt that
we could have gone
through this process faster
finding that ends quicker
so that we could have moved
on and created more prototypes
and gone even further
in our project.
PROFESSOR: Great.
Thanks very much.
[APPLAUSE]
We will get questions
from the panelists first.
Rob, Julie?
ROB MILLER: Sure, I can start.
So how many of these prototypes
showed a whole range of things?
Which of those actually
made it into Kate's ears?
JENNY: [INAUDIBLE] step back.
This prototype, the
3D printed piece,
is something we're
actually going to go with.
And all of them made
it onto Kate's ears.
She wore them all at
some point, but this
is the final, final one.
And then the coil that you see
in the middle-- this one here
is made out of Instamorph,
and we decided not to 3D-print
that, because this is already
of pretty good quality--
or of quality good
enough that we wanted
to use for our final prototype.
So this is also going
to be used as well.
JULIE GREENBERG: Could
you go to the slide
that shows the sound testing?
JENNY: Yeah.
JULIE GREENBERG: And could
you-- [INAUDIBLE] OK.
So your results show
that it was enhanced
a little bit-- the sounds
coming from the front.
And it was mostly suppression
of sounds coming from the rear?
JENNY: Yes.
JULIE GREENBERG:
And that was all
tested with the 1000Hz tone?
JENNY: Yeah.
JULIE GREENBERG: Or were
there multiple frequencies?
PHILLIP ABEL: There were
multiple frequencies
at which we tested.
JULIE GREENBERG: Becasue
these are the results?
PHILLIP ABEL: So these are the
results that we got from that.
I think Dhruv was
the one in charge
of the sound
directionality test.
DHRUV: So actually it was
tested at different frequencies.
Like the normal frequencies
for getting an audiogram, which
is [INAUDIBLE] from
250Hz, then it's goes up
to eight kilohertz.
But the results that
we have accumulated
are just for one frequency,
which is like one kilohertz,
but in the final report
that we're [INAUDIBLE],
we will mention about
all the differences,
with all the tables and do that.
So just to give an idea of how
the tech performed we actually
mentioned only one kind of
frequency in the presentation.
JULIE GREENBERG: OK.
Thank you.
I wanted to understand this, but
now I want to ask the addition.
So at the beginning
you mentioned--
so I wanted to see
if you could clarify
both what the goals
were in terms of--
was it about distinguishing
sounds front and back,
or was it suppressing
some and enhancing others?
DHRUV: Could you
repeat the question?
I'm sorry, I'm
having hearing loss.
Could you repeat the question?
JULIE GREENBERG: Was
the goal of the design
distinguish where the sound
the sound was coming from,
or to help her hear some
sounds and not others depending
on the direction?
DHRUV: I would say no to both.
It was more about
blocking sound from behind
and enhancing sound from front.
So [INAUDIBLE] just about
analyzing the 2D space
around Kate so that they could
block the background noise
and actually
understand that it's
coming from the
conversation in the front.
JULIE GREENBERG: So you
were using direction
to define what was desirable
and what was undesirable.
DHRUV: Exactly, exactly.
I mean it was not
very well-defined,
but you could see
the field of view
that we have catered here, from
the [INAUDIBLE] field of view.
it was about 135
degrees, and we were
able to argue that
in the field of view
that is about 135 degrees
for a normal [? woman, ?]
we were able to enhance sound.
And from the behind, that is,
outside the field of view,
we reduced the sound.
JULIE GREENBERG: So how did that
goal then affect your design?
Because the other thing
that I was hoping your
could calrify-- I think this is
a question for the whole team--
is the fact that
at one point you
said Kate wanted
modular solutions,
but you attempted
to design something
that would provide both
the water-resistance
and the sound-blocking
in a single device.
So how did that
all fit together?
RAQUEL: So what
you said is right.
Our first thought was,
let's make one large cover
that can provide the
rain protection and also
some sound-blocking.
But she wanted a more
modular approach, I think,
because it's not always
raining, and you don't always
need this large cover.
So she wanted something
smaller that she can just
put on a little bit
more discreetly.
Like if she's in a
meeting, for example,
and she's really more focused
on the sound directionality,
or she's out with her friends,
and she's really more focused
on hearing what they're
saying in a noisy environment.
JULIE GREENBERG: Do you
design two different things?
I guess I'm still confused.
You designed two different
things, and which one of that--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
RAQUEL: So we did design
two different things.
So one is a set of rain covers.
So a cover for
the ear processor,
which is the curved part, and
then a cover for the coil,
that you see on the right here.
And then the left picture
is the separate piece, which
is the sound-blocking piece.
PROFESSOR: OK.
I think in the interest of
time, we have to move on,
but thank you team Kate.
I think you've done great
work sort of prototyping
through this [INAUDIBLE].
All right great, we're
going to do Team Chris next.
If you can get set
up, that'd great.
CAROLYN: I'm Carolyn, and this
is Phoebe, Durk, and Aarti.
And we are Team Chris.
So some context on our
client-- his activities
that he wants to do and his
assistive technology-- is
that Chris is an MBA
student at Boston College,
and he has a genetic condition
called Miyoshi Myopathy.
Miyoshi Myopathy is a late-onset
form of muscular dystrophy.
So when Chris was
about 22, he started
to feel some weakness
in his muscles,
especially in his legs.
And now he uses
crutches and a scooter,
depending upon the
distance that he wants
to go on campus and at home.
So because he uses
these devices,
he needs to know a little bit
more about his surroundings
before he leaves.
He needs to know if his
route is accessible,
and if his destination is
going to be accessible for him.
And right now uses a
few different things
to help them with that.
He uses Google Maps.
He uses Yelp, and
sometimes he even
calls ahead to see what the
features of the building
are before he arrives.
But what he really
needs is something
that's more centralized
and more comprehensive
so he knows exactly what
his route will look like
and exactly what features
are in the building
before he leaves his house.
So that's what we tried to do,
is create a central location
for all of that data, so
that he has one place to go,
and he will know
ahead of time if he's
going to be able to use the
building the way he wants to.
PHOEBE: So to do that
we made a website
called Successible
Maps, and we based it
on Boston College first,
to scope it down a bit.
Our first step was to
make paper prototypes.
So each team member made
pretty much drawings
of what we thought the
website should look like.
This consisted of either
text or just image-based,
and we presented
this to Chris, and he
picked his favorite features
out of each of them,
and we use that feedback
to create our second paper
prototype.
And here, his feedback was that
he liked the map interface,
and he liked how we had pop-ups
for obstacles such as potholes,
as well as a bigger
pop up on top
of each buildings for
plans, and in there,
flags of obstacles
inside the building
and pictures of different rooms.
Feedback on this
prototype included
a clear distinction
between the floor plan
and the text description
we had of each floor,
as well as a summary page
for every building-- that's
a general overview of
different entrances
and exits for every building.
Our next prototype--
sets of prototypes
are the software
prototypes, which
included our back-end
model of the data,
such as buildings, and
flags, for floor plans,
as well as the front-end of how
the website would look and feel
for our client.
The feedback for this
was that Chris liked it,
and he wanted to see a couple
more icons such as an elevator
icon, as well as time stamps
for every flag obstacle,
or obstacle flag,
or things that pop
up, so that he can keep
track of what is actually
recent and relevant.
DURK: As far as our
success metrics go,
we had three main criteria we
were looking at, one of which
is the number of clicks
it takes to access
the information, second of
which is how long it actually
takes to get the information
Chris is interested in.
And finally, the amount
of certainty that he is
left with after
using the application
to get all of the information.
To address this, we tried to
design that all into our app.
So I can give a quick
demonstration right now.
So we created it-- let's see.
So our app ended up-- sorry
about that-- Sorry, just
a second here, and
I'll pull it up
to show you exactly what we did.
It is a-- there we go.
Sorry about that.
So we have two different
methods in which
we went about
presenting information
that Chris is interested in.
The first of which is we have
various flags that call out
for different information.
So, for example,
accessible entrances--
you can click on the
flag, and it tells you
that, say, this is the only
accessible door to Stokes Hall,
and that specific information
about that location
as it's overlaid on the
Google Maps-- you can see
what it actually looks like.
We also have things like alerts
at various other locations
that can call attention to other
types of information that might
not be seen in other manners.
Finally, on buildings, you can
click on the building itself
and view the information about
the building and its floor
plans.
So you can click on
an individual floor,
and see the floor plan,
and pieces of information
about the floor
such as locations
of accessible
bathrooms, or where
the elevators are located.
Now Chris stated that as
far as our metrics go,
we succeeded on the metric
of the number of clicks
as it takes less than
three to get to the desired
information about the buildings,
and as far as the actual time
that it takes to
accomplish it, Chris
said using previous methods,
he would take up to 20 minutes
to figure out a route
from building to building,
and with our app he
believes he can do it
in five to 10 minutes.
So a 50% to 75%
reduction there, which
we were pretty happy about.
And then he found it
very easy to utilize,
and it was able to find the
relevant information very
quickly.
He gave us a couple
more pieces of feedback,
which we are going to
continue to incorporate in,
such as adding the
labels onto the buildings
to say what their names are,
and some images actually
into the flags and the alerts to
show more specific information.
AARTI: So a few of
the lessons that we
learned throughout the semester
while working on this project--
so specifically for Chris--
for his specific problem,
we learned that things that
are labeled as accessible
don't necessarily mean
they're accessible to him.
So, in general,
what he wanted us
to do for the semester was
gather the specific facts
that he can use and figure out
for himself if the facility is
accessible for him,
because he didn't want
to trust other
people's opinions,
because it's not necessarily
true for him specifically.
And so other lessons we
learned, which were overall
assistive technology-specific
or just design-specific
where that you really need to
get to your client really well.
So you have to get
to know their needs,
their specific wants, and
don't go in with assumptions.
So we went in with
a few, but they
were knocked down once we just
had conversations with him.
And also, in general, universal
design is really difficult,
and you happen to think
really hard about it.
So the product that we
made is specific for Chris,
but if we want to make
it accessible to people
with different types
of disabilities,
there's a lot more work
that we have to put into it.
Overall engineering
lessons that we learned
were one, to continue to use
the iterative design process.
And, for our team specifically,
a huge lesson we learned
was throughout the
semester we separated tasks
and we were very
modular with it.
So we separated front-end
from back-end entirely.
But when we wanted to put
them together a few weeks ago,
it became really difficult,
because the front-end people
didn't know what was
happening in back-end,
back-end didn't know front-end.
And so we learned that
we have to continue
throughout the semester
to at least update
each other on what's
going on so that we
know in general what's happening
in the whole scope of things.
And so that's what we
learned this semester.
Thank you.
Any questions?
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR: Thanks very much.
We can go to the panelists.
ROB MILLER: You said
that Chris thought
that he would be able to
[INAUDIBLE] four times as
[INAUDIBLE].
Did you actually [INAUDIBLE]
anything on that?
Did you [INAUDIBLE]?
DURK: Yeah, so
the reason that we
said that is that we did model
it after the Boston College
campus, which he is
already familiar with.
So he did actually go through
the process of looking up
the information,
but I mean-- so he
thought that he could
do it in that time,
because that's what it
took him to look it up.
Even though he's already
familiar with it,
it's not really an
unfamiliar place.
We chose to focus
on Boston College
because it was more directly--
we had the information,
and we could get a
better idea of what
it was he wanted, because
he had sort of seen all
of the bad parts and knew
what information he wished he
would have known at that point.
PROFESSOR: Julie, questions?
OK.
I have a question just on
the data side of things.
The data that you use
to populate your map--
did you hand-collect
that, and are there
certain sources
of data that might
be useful for the rest of
campus or for other sort
of structured data
sets that might
be useful for a
project like yours?
DURK: So the right now,
we put in all of the data
that we're using.
But one thing I
didn't actually show
is that users can input new
information into the app.
So they're able to add
new flags very easily
as well as new buildings,
new floors onto buildings,
and update that
with information.
So right now it is fully
dependent upon users
to input the
information, but any user
can put that information
into the database.
PROFESSOR: Other
questions from mentors
or from students in the class?
Anyone?
OK.
I think your team has really
done some interesting work,
some very good work on this
campus accessibility question
or this environmental
accessibility question.
So well done.
Great.
Thanks a lot.
[? IAN: Hi, ?] everyone.
My name is [? Ian, ?]
and this is Christina,
and our third member
Jane is not here today.
But our team is Team
Don, and we created
an app called Your
Friendly Reminder.
Your Friendly Reminder
is a reminder system
that will send daily
emails to our client Don,
and allow him to see his
list of calendar events
in the early afternoon
where he typically tends
to have a cognitive deficit.
So first we'll go through
the background of our client
and then you in a little bit
about our design process,
and how we kind of
came to this design,
and then we'll go through
our final prototype
and along with our testing
and our reflections.
CHRISTINA: So a little bit
of background about Don--
he lives independently, but
he's actually very active,
and he's an advocate for
people with disabilities,
so he goes out to meetings
all the time to speak at them.
And during his childhood
he contracted Polio,
which affected his left leg.
And back in 2002,
he had a stroke,
and this limited the use of
the left side of his body.
And as a result, he has
cognitive difficulties,
which is what we focused
on for our project
during the semester.
So about his cognitive
difficulties--
around 2:00 PM every
day, on a typical day,
he would start to have trouble
processing his thoughts,
and it affects how he can
communicate with people.
So one of the things that
we wanted to focus on
was, since he's a
very busy person,
was to help him remind be
reminded of and encouraged
to complete his tasks
that he has scheduled
throughout the day
and also to ensure
that he acknowledges the
reminders rather than ignoring
them.
So some of us is
the technologies
that he currently uses-- he
uses a leg brace to make sure
that he doesn't
hyper-extend his knee.
He also uses a cane
to help him walk.
He has Velcro on
his shoes, but one
of the most important pieces
of technology that he relies on
is his iPhone.
And so he pretty much
stores everything
on his iPhone,
everything about his day,
and he keeps notes
on his iPhone.
And currently, he enters all
of the events for his day
into his Yahoo calendar which
then is imported into his iCal,
and then he accesses
his events from there.
And from then, he gets reminders
about when his events are
and what they are.
So from this, we wanted to
create a reminder system that
would not only remind him of
his upcoming tasks for the day,
but also encourage him to stay
focused while he's experiencing
cognitive overload.
And the goals of our project
was to make the reminders more
gentle and humane so that
he would be encouraged
to actually look at them.
And reminders that
would help him
internalize what
the upcoming tasks
are rather than just dismissing
them, as he does now.
And we also wanted to make
sure that his calendar could
be backed up, because
that's something
that is very important to him.
So for our first
prototype, we actually
thought of making an app and.
So we had and test
out a paper prototype
of this app where he
could enter in his events,
and it would create
a reminder for him.
And we were thinking
about ways to make
this more of an interaction
where it would--
rather than stressing
him out with,
oh, you have all these events
for the rest of the day;
it would help him to
calm down and focus.
[? IAN: And ?] so one thing we
figured out about this design
is that we're basically just
creating a new application that
already does what iCal does.
And so we went to
our second design,
where we used Google scripts to
import his events from Google
Calendar and use
that information
to be able to reformat it and
send him an email that will
show him his list of events.
So you can see here in
our second iteration
that we were able to
grab his calendar events,
but it's just in a list form.
So he is PPAT, AAPT,
REMINDER, et cetera.
And these calender events would
be listed in a single list,
so that Don could simply look
at this email in the afternoon
and be like, OK, I
have all these events,
and this is just
one more thing that
will help me make sure
I complete everything
successfully and attend all
of the events that I need to.
And so we move from
this to our third,
iteration where we were
able to focus on what it
would look like in his phone.
And so we wanted our reminders
to be more gentle and more
humane, rather than a little
pop-up from Apple or Siri
saying, reminder, you have
x event-- snooze, or OK,
or dismiss.
And so with this
Google script, we
were able to send him a
cute little email that
not only would that not
only had an image of a cute
puppy, or a kitten, or something
like that, but also had colors,
and it was personalized.
And we found out
later that Don really
like the idea of having
a personalized email
just for him.
And so this email-- we called
it your friendly reminder,
and we were able to use
all of the information
that he already has, but
be able to use it in a way
to where he looks at
it and he feels good.
And so one of the
problems that we ran into
is that we really wanted
a response system.
And so we wanted
to send an email.
We wanted him to be able
to look at this email.
But how are we going to check
to see if we could do that.
We didn't really want
to hack into his email
and check what time he read
it, and so the way that we
decided to implement this was
to have a response system.
So he would simply
respond muffins
or whatever keyword we had.
And so you can see right
here, there's a little text,
and it'll be bigger in a second.
To stop these reminders, reply
to this email with the word
muffins.
And so he would reply to this
email with the word muffins,
and then we would send him
another follow-up email saying,
thanks for your reply.
We got your message.
And so one thing
we found is that he
didn't like the continuous
spamming of the emails, which
I'm sure we can all relate to.
And so we worked through
that, which I'll tell you
a little bit about in a second.
And so our final
prototype removes
these constant reminders.
And so there's
just one email that
will send to him within an
hour if he hasn't responded.
And then we want to still
be able to have this reply
mechanism so that we
can still make sure
that he reads the email,
because as annoying as it
is to keep on
receiving emails, we
want him to look at this email,
and we want it to be effective.
So here's an example of what
a sequence would look like.
So you'd send him an email
in the early afternoon.
So this one was sent
around to 2:26 PM.
And so you can see
his events for today.
And we changed the
keyword to brownie.
And then there's another
cute kitty picture,
and so we-- in our back-end
we have a rotation of these.
And so you can see that
Don checks his email quite
frequently, and he
responded within one minute,
responding the word brownie.
And so we, in response, sent
him one last email saying,
got your message.
Thanks for replying
and have a great day.
And so this is what our
final prototype looks like.
And so we tested it
on him-- like I said,
we first tested it
with trying to find
a balance between sending
him too many emails
but ensuring that
he checks our email
and doesn't dismiss it
like his other reminders.
And so he found them
to be kind of annoying.
He I might have even said,
"I find it harassing"."
So we tried to limit that to
two emails, because we still
wanted to see what was
the threshold of emails
we could send before he really
got so annoyed at us that he
would chuck his
phone at the door.
And so he still
found them annoying,
but then we tried testing them
with zero follow-up emails,
and we found that he still liked
the idea of having to respond
and having someone A.K.A Your
Friendly Reminder follow up
on him within an hour to
make sure that he checked.
And so, in
conclusion, we've also
learned that it's challenging
to evaluate a system like this.
How do we each how do we
use our success metrics?
And how do we use data
points such as the time
we send emails, the time
he responds to emails,
and how do we make sure
that this product is
effective for him?
And so we found that that
was really difficult to do,
but I think we were
able to, because one
of the things he said was "It's
one more step that leads me
to the end."
It might be one more
thing that will ultimately
lead me to the end
of the day where
I've completed all my tasks,
even though I do have it
in my calendar.
I can look at it myself,
but one more email helps me.
And so a little aside--
after the 10th time,
the puppy gets old.
So we start switching the
pictures to different kittens,
and frogs, and little puppies.
So our final prototype
was something
that we believe will
really help him,
and that we believe
will really allow
him to have more gentle humane
reminders that will ultimately
help him with his cognitive
deficit in the early afternoon.
And the next steps were
looking for a work-around.
And we've already
talked about this,
so I will ask for questions.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR: Questions
from the panel?
Julie, Rob?
JULIE GREENBERG: So
I think you're right.
It is challenging to
evaluate a system like this.
But if you had a lot more
time and resources, what would
a more rigorous
evaluation look like?
So currently, we have a
Google doc in the back-end
where all of the
data that we have,
including what time the
emails are sent out,
what time he responds to them,
and what time our system is
responding to him-- we
have a few data points.
But it's only about
three days worth
since we've implemented
this Google Doc,
but we've been testing this
for probably about a week
and a half to two weeks.
And each, probably,
couple of days,
we'll get some
sort of reminder--
we'll get improvements
that we will implement.
Does that answer your question.
For example, the sending him
two follow-up emails rather than
four.
ROB MILLER: Do you know if
this is having any effect?
But I love the way you
expressed one of your goals
as getting him to
internalize the [INAUDIBLE],
not just look at
it and dismiss it.
Do you have any idea about
whether this is [INAUDIBLE]?
[? IAN: We ?] do not.
One of the things
we really want to
was to find how many times
he comes back to this email.
Because what we would like
for him to do is at 5:00 PM,
be like, oh what do I
have going on today?
Let me go back to this email
that Your Friendly Reminder has
sent him.
So no we do not have that data.
The only thing we have is
just his personal feelings
about it-- whether he
feels like it helps him.
And he says that it
has, and so we're
hoping that-- at this
point it's enough for us
to feel like we've
done something.
ROB MILLER: A follow-up
question actually
also about internalization.
So this keyword idea
for replying rather than
just [INAUDIBLE] button
there, then [INAUDIBLE].
Runs the script
and checks it off.
But the keyword is
interesting, because it
seems like there's a
possibility that you
can help him
internalize it by making
the keyword relevant to what
he's supposed to do, instead
of just muffins, unless
he actually is supposed
to bake some muffins.
[LAUGHTER]
But if he's supposed to do
something else, [INAUDIBLE].
Did you think about that?
Did you talk about that?
GUEST SPEAKER: The keywords
are currently just randomized.
We were thinking
of doing something
along the lines of
reading through his events
and then picking out
a word from that event
and then making that the
keyword, and that's something
we did debate, but we never
really implemented that,
because we wanted to
add the other features,
but that is something
that we have thought,
and is a good idea, and
that we could implement.
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
have you thought
of using this
application for persons
with other types
of disabilities,
such as psychiatric or
abnormal [INAUDIBLE]?
GUEST SPEAKER: Well right now,
a lot of stuff is hard-coded,
so we can't really extend
this of more than one user.
And that is something that
we do want to try to expand,
but apparently-- I tried
to look all over Google,
and they don't save your
first name for some reason.
So even your first
name is hard-coded,
and that's something
that we would
need to step away from in order
to expand this to other users.
But that's something that
we would really like to do.
AUDIENCE: I think cognitive
overload is something
hard to empathize
with sometimes What
were your experiences
trying to empathize with Don
during this entire semester?
GUEST SPEAKER: So I think
the biggest one that did
affect us was trying to
get conversations steered
n a direction-- it's
understandable that you have
a lot of stuff
going in your mind,
and just simply keeping a
conversation going on one way
did prove to be a little bit
tougher than we expected,
but that is part of
the cognitive overload,
to have one goal in mind.
And it was hard to empathize
with that at the beginning,
but the more we did
interact with Don,
we understood that
this is an issue,
and it's not his or
our fault, and we
understood that we
needed something
to make this better for him.
PROFESSOR: Maybe
related to that,
can you talk a little bit
about the design process?
does that mean
that sometimes you
have to kind of push or nudge
ideas in a certain direction?
How do you sort of navigate
this user input in this process?
GUEST SPEAKER: So
just getting ideas
at the beginning of the project
was a little bit tricky.
Especially-- if you
guys didn't know,
we actually started off with
a different project for most
of the semester,
and then we decide
to switch gears and go something
more software-oriented, and was
definitely a tough
process to go through,
but once we got something
going, it was a lot easier
to streamline the process.
PROFESSOR: OK.
I know that your team has had
quite a ride this semester,
but I think that has come up
with something very promising
with some interesting results.
So well done.
Great.
[APPLAUSE]
GUEST SPEAKER: Hi guys,
we're team Jeffrey,
and then we're here to
present our product, which
is called touch 'n' sign.
GUEST SPEAKER:
Which Jeffrey named.
GUEST SPEAKER: Yeah.
So let's give a
little overview first.
So our client is Jeffrey.
He's sitting right over there.
So his disability
is that he's blind,
and generally he
lives with himself,
but sometimes he has a
seeing aide at his house,
and he actually goes
out quite frequently.
Like sometimes he goes
out to the neighborhoods,
but every week or
so, he'll sometimes
go out to further places
like to watch a movie
or to catch an opera.
And he's also a
pretty active member
of a number of
community organizations.
And, as such, he's in
charges of financial matters
as well as other matters.
And because of
this, he often needs
to sign legal documents
or other important papers.
So the goal of our assistive
technology for this semester
is to have a way for him to sign
these legal documents that he
needs to sign without the
help of his seeing aide.
And so before, usually he just
has his seeing aide come over,
and then he'll manually guide
Jeffrey's hand to the place he
needs to sign, but sometimes he
can always be at his house. .
So then we wanted to
come up with a way
for him to be able to sign
his signature on the paper,
even when his seeing
aide wasn't there.
And sometimes, for
certain organizations,
they actually need his actual,
written signature on the paper.
So like sometimes we thought
about maybe just somehow
printing it on there, or some
other way of electronically
putting it on
there, but they need
this thing called
a wet signature.
So then this was not
always a possible solution.
So what with Jeffrey
has already is
he has a software
called JAWS, which
is this really cool
software for blind people
on the PC that essentially reads
out what's on the computer.
And it's like pretty
intuitive, and it's
a very detailed in
terms of the things
that it can describe to you.
He also has an OCR software, and
Optical Character Recognition
software, or he has
someone that can
do for him, in which he can
convert general documents
into Word documents that
has the same characters
in the same places.
So what he needs
is in two steps.
The first step is he needs some
way, given a Word document,
to find where he needs to
sign on the Word document.
So if you're given an
electronic Word document,
he needs a way to know
on this document, where
the signature is.
And then after he
has that, he needs
to-- from that information,
on the physical document
he needs to be able to locate
that on the physical document.
So then we broke it
up into two steps.
And then the first step
is like a software step
and then the second
step is a hardware step.
GUEST SPEAKER: So basically
here is the software design.
So the first design
we have activates
through a macro toolbar
in the Microsoft Word.
So you can see
that whenever which
we find the signature file where
we first scan the documents,
and then we locate-- so
JAWS will read underscore,
underscore,
underscore, so we know
that it's a signature field.
So then we trigger
the macro we have.
So it reads out the
horizontal position and also
the vertical position,
basically giving
Jeffrey x-y coordinates to work
on at the mechanical solution
part.
And it also tells him
which pages it is on.
And also, for the
final design, we
basically simplified this thing
that Jeffrey needs to remember
and also the action
that he has to do.
So we activate the
macro through hot keys,
and also we have more
intuitive wording,
and also we rounded
the decimal place,
because it doesn't have
to be too accurate.
So the hardware
design iteration one.
So the approach we have is
that we do fast prototyping.
We have like
multiple iterations.
So this is the very
first design we have.
So the feature it had is
completely made by cardboard
and also floss.
And also along
the board, you can
see that there are
dots along the edge
to indicate the coordinates.
So the x-y bar are tied on
the floss to slice through.
So the feedback we got is
that it's not accurate enough
like for Jeffrey to
read the numbers,
and also it's hard it's
hard to put the paper on,
because the x-y rails
are tied onto the board.
And also Jeffrey has to count
the number of the bumps.
So if he's interrupted, he
has to count again, which
is not very convenient for him.
And also the second design
is that we improved it
by using a magnet bar, instead
of using the bump that we
manually made by the cardboard.
So it's easy to slide,
but then the guided bars
are still too thin
to be accurately
lined up so that you can be
very horizontal and vertical.
And also the movement
on the magnetic stripe
is not smooth enough, because
the cardboard is not even,
and also it's hard to tell
if the rails were straight.
GUEST SPEAKER: So this
is our third design.
So we took Jeffrey's advice, and
we made the board a lot bigger,
because he wanted
to have shoulders
so that if, for example,
if he needed to sign really
close to the edge of
the paper, we would be
able to move the rail to that.
So for the third
design, we wanted
to do something different.
We added the braille ruler
onto the horizontal guide bar
so that after he finds
the vertical position,
he can simply move his hand
along the Braille ruler
on the horizontal bar
in order to figure out
the x part, the
horizontal position of it.
But the feedback that we got
was that the thicker guide bars
made it a lot more
easy to line up,
because we had the
braille rulers on the side
so that if we had a three--
if the guide bars are
three inches wide, then
he could line it up
against the braille ruler
and have it be very straight.
And that was pretty accurate.
But the problem was that like
this design demanded too much
of the user, because if
you had to use one hand
to move down the bar, and then
you had to use the other hand
to move along the
horizontal position,
it was very hard to keep track
of the horizontal position
and sign at the same time.
So Jeffrey actually preferred
like the previous design
that we had over this one.
So we don't have a picture
here, but basically
what we did for
the third iteration
prime is we took stuff
from the third design,
but instead of just
having just one guide
bar with a horizontal
ruler attached to it,
we put the horizontal
braille ruler onto the board,
and then we added onto
it another guide bar,
so he would be able to
move two guide bars,
and not have to keep track of
the position with his hands.
And then we still used
the same base as before.
So the feedback that we got
was that again like the thicker
guide bars made it
a lot more accurate,
and then it was a lot more easy
to use than the previous one.
OK, so we actually found
online at this place
called MaxiAid, something
that does the same thing
that we were trying to do.
So we bought it, and we
tried to test it out.
So it's like a commercial
product built on a clipboard,
and it has a ruler
that goes down.
And then it has a thing that
clicks if you move it across,
so you can find
the x-y positions.
But the feedback was
that Jeffrey really
liked the idea of
holding stuff down
with the clipboard, because
it makes it really stable.
And he likes the
stability of it,
but the problem was
that it was just not
a very accurate
solution, because it
wobbled around a lot.
It could only click, and the
clicks were hard to count.
And there was no place on the
board for a Braille ruler,
so it was hard to
find the position.
So our final prototype--
we decided to kind of just
make a higher fidelity
version of the third design
that we had, and instead
of having tapered edges,
we decided to go with
just non-tapered edges,
because that would
make it easier.
Because we didn't really see the
point of having tapered edges,
and we made the
whole board magnetic
so that it'd be easier
for the rails to stick on,
and they wouldn't fall off.
And it's very similar
to the third design.
GUEST SPEAKER: We're going
to watch a video of him
using the software.
So right now he's trying
to find where the signature
bar is on the [INAUDIBLE].
JULIE GREENBERG: Oh,
is that JAWS talking?
GUEST SPEAKER: Yeah.
GUEST SPEAKER: This
is his computer, yeah.
GUEST SPEAKER: All right.
So I solved.
Wow, that's super.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: Can you tale 30
seconds and wrap up please?
GUEST SPEAKER: Yeah.
This is him, and this
is what the result was.
And then we measured
a bunch of--
GUEST SPEAKER: We wanted to
know how accurate it was,
how fast it took him to use
the mechanical prototype,
and what he thought of
his overall satisfaction,
and these are kind of like
the summary of his results.
And then there are
a lot of things
that we learned through this.
GUEST SPEAKER: So basically
the first thing that we learned
was that there could
be a lot of challenges
that we didn't predict, and
also the fast prototyping
actually helps so that we
can make more iterations.
And the second is
that the details
are the most important part
while we are doing the design.
And the third is that we need
to take into account the burdens
that we have on our client.
And also the manual
testing is very important
to find the flaws and the bugs.
And the fifth thing is that
nothing can be really perfect.
We have to make a trade-offs.
So we have to choose
what we value more.
And the last thing
is that documentation
is really important.
It's easy to fall behind, so
it's really hard to make it up.
And that's a good ending.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
Let' start with questions
on from the panel.
ROB MILLER: I'm going to use my
question to ask you to back up
to the slide where you
showed the numbers,
just so that we can look
at them a little bit more.
What do you think happened
overall on design [INAUDIBLE]?
GUEST SPEAKER: Because it
was a commercial product.
ROB MILLER: Oh, that
was the MaxiAid.
GUEST SPEAKER: So
we wanted to see
what we could take from
that, and we [INAUDIBLE]
the clip art that
stabilized the paper.
But in terms of accuracy,
it was hard for Jeffrey
to count the clicks.
ROB MILLER: So which one
is the final clipboard
prototype that you did?
GUEST SPEAKER: So
we have it here.
ROB MILLER: OK, but it's
not in this [INAUDIBLE].
GUEST SPEAKER: No, it's not.
I mean we didn't test it yet.
GUEST SPEAKER: Any
other questions?
Raquel?
RAQUEL: Can you go back
to explain the accuracy?
Like how many times
did you test it?
How did you determine
how accurate it was?
Was it one time?
GUEST SPEAKER: Yeah, we tested
it a few times for each,
and then we
essentially looked at--
so generally the accuracy
for how wobbly it was
was not a problem.
it was essentially where the
signature line started versus
where he started signing it.
And then we just took
the average of those.
ROB MILLER: What
did you find more
challenging in this project--
the software side of it
or the hardware side
of the [INAUDIBLE]
of an accurate measurement
of the [INAUDIBLE].
GUEST SPEAKER: I
think personally
found the hardware side
a bit more challenging.
I think we are more towards the
software side as our studies,
so it's more out of our comfort
zone the do the hardware side.
And part of it is also
iterating on hardware
is more of a
time-intensive process.
GUEST SPEAKER: I think we had
hard time trying to scope out
our project-- do we want to
handle documents of all sizes,
or do we just want to do it for
8.5" by 11" pieces of paper.
And I think we wanted to make
the hardware solution very
elegant, so it
took a lot of time
to figure out how to make
it so that it's easy to use
and simple enough to understand.
GUEST SPEAKER: And also, a lot
of challenges that Jeffrey had
using our project, we cannot
see well during the design.
For example, he wanted the
entire surface to be flat.
And also, he wants to be able
to have a [? bump ?] to align
with the bar.
So we kind of don't know that
when [? were ?] [? able ?]
to see everything, but when he
used it within-- at that time,
we realized what the flaw of
the design is so we can redo
the thing.
PROFESSOR: OK I think this team
has done some great iterations
and made good use of
Jeffrey's abilities.
So well done.
All right.
Thank you
[APPLAUSE]
We'll let Team Felicity set up.
ARI: Hi everyone.
So our product is vibeAware.
My name is Ari, and these are
my teammates Becca and Simi.
And our client is Felicity.
Felicity has neurofibromatosis,
which has, as a result,
left her profoundly deaf
and with low vision.
However Felicity is
very active, and she
tends to go out with friends,
she has doctor appointments,
goes to cafes, and of
all of these activities,
she notices that it's
really hard for other people
to get her attention.
So that's why we decided
to create vibeAware.
VibeAware is a device
with two components.
The first one Felicity
wears and the other one
she gives to a friend.
When the friend wants to notify
Felicity and get her attention,
they can just a toggle
the button on the remote
and then Felicity will get
a vibration that'll let her
be aware that someone's
trying to notify her.
Hence the terrible word pun.
And we're going to talk
about the design process.
SIMI: So through our project
we used an iterative design
process.
And our iterations
went as follows.
Our first design was
a toy car spin-off.
Our second design
was a light ring.
Then we created a custom circuit
and finally, refined that
to our final design.
And I'll go over those
more specifically now.
So in our first
iteration, we asked
ourselves the question,
how do we get an RF
signal to trigger a motor.
We're all software-focused
in our studies,
so we don't really know
a lot about hardware.
So we thought that
the best way to do
this is to use something
that's already out there.
And that is a toy car.
A toy car has two
switches that essentially
trigger two different
motors using an RF signal.
So we took apart a toy car, and
we learnt a lot through this
process.
We learnt about RF signals.
We learnt about how this works,
what components are necessary
to make it work.
And through this design,
we kind of played around
to see what we could get-- how
big of a design we could get.
But our pros in this design
were that we learnt about RF
signals; we found something
that works at a long range.
The cons are obviously
that it's huge, and bulky,
and it has a lot of
pieces that we don't need,
and it's not customized.
So we went to our
next iteration,
and we asked
ourselves the question
is it possible to create
this with a smaller design?
Again, we went with something
that's already out there.
We went with this little
tiny light switch that
basically is remote controlled.
And we kind of hacked that to
create our own little vibeAware
ring.
So this essentially
is a little light
with a motor attached
that we hacked on,
and the remote
control essentially
turns on the motor
as a notification.
The pros of this
design were that it
was very light and
small, but the cons
were that it works at
a very limited range,
the battery was short-lived,
and the circuit was just hacked,
it wasn't customized to
what we wanted it to do.
But we got something to work.
So now we're going to talk
about iteration three, which
basically progressed our
design further by three steps.
We asked ourselves the question,
can we get better range
with a smaller device?
And Ari's going to
talk more about this.
ARI: So the first
thing we felt was
that we weren't going to
be able to reach our design
objectives using off
the shelf hardware,
and we'd have to go and
create our own circuit.
So this is our first end-to-end
custom circuit product
that we made.
[CLAPPING]
[LAUGHTER]
And I'll talk about what we did.
So basically we did a search on
different hardware components
that we'd like to use.
We ended up getting a small
cellphone vibration motor
from sparkfun.
And the other
component we had was
the receiver and the key fob.
So this was great.
This had a remote control
that was already made,
and a corresponding chip that
we just had to supply power to.
You didn't need any
other microcontrollers
or extra stuff.
And when you hit the remote,
it would set one of the pins
to high on this
transmitter/receiver device.
It had up to 25 feet
of range, depending
on line-of-sight obstructions,
and it was only $12.
So using that and
other basic components
like LEDs, push buttons, we
were able to create this design.
So we started with
this schematic,
and we had different-- pretty
much the easiest way you
could try to set this thing up.
We tested it out
on a breadboard,
and then we tried to put it
all into a small proto-board.
And afterwards, we put
it in a cardboard box.
So surprisingly, Felicity
was really excited
when she received this, but
we felt that we could probably
do a little bit better.
And so the pros of it was it
was our fully functional circuit
design.
It had longer range
than the ring,
and it was much smaller
than our RC car.
The con was we really
didn't spend time thinking
about the enclosure.
This one also had a
very large battery pack,
and again, the circuit
wasn't completely closed,
so it was a little bit fragile.
So after this we said,
how can we improve this?
How can we make it more durable?
BECCA: So I'm Becca, and I'll
talk about this final design
that we put together.
So the goal of the
final design was
to make something that was a
bit more durable and compact,
and so what we decided to do
was create an acrylic shell
for our final
circuit, and we also
want to think about how we could
make the vibration a little bit
more strong.
And so we decided to go
with a nine volt battery,
instead of the smaller batteries
that we were using before.
And in this final design we've
considered both maintainability
and also usability.
Because we were using
this nine volt battery
we have to make some
minor circuit adjustments.
So since the receiver
uses five volt,
we had to use a linear
voltage regulator
to interface to two components.
And so we edited that.
And also in this
final design, we
had to consider how Felicity
was going be using it,
and so how these various
components like the motor,
the switches, the
LED, and the battery
were going to be positioned
in the final design.
So I'll talk a bit
about this later,
but these are just sketches
of us brainstorming
as we were thinking about it.
And also, as we were
thinking about this,
we decided to make the final
design a necklace instead,
because at one point
in our interview,
Felicity had mentioned that
her sternum area is one
of her most sensitive areas.
And so if we could leverage
that, and put a motor
next to that, we thought
that the notification
would be more effective.
And so when were making
the acrylic shelling,
we first designed
it in the software,
and then just used
a laser cutter
to create the acrylic shelling.
And that's what
you can see here.
And this was the
size we had to make
in order for the battery and
the circuit to fit inside of it.
And so this is our final design.
It's actually a
shiny black encasing,
but we had to tape it when
were first testing it out,
but as you can see, first
the antenna has to pop out,
because we wanted to
maximize the signal strength,
and we put the LED at the
top of the necklace device
so that it maximizes the
visibility when she sees it.
And we have two switches.
So one switch is she
flips it on when she first
wants to use the device.
And the LED will turn on
that so she knows it's on.
Then when her friend
triggers the device
and it starts vibrating, she
can press a second switch,
which is a push button
to reset the device
and turn off the vibration.
But the device will
keep on listening
until she switches off the LED.
And so when we're
positioning the switches,
we knew that Felicity
was right-handed,
and so we put the
switches accordingly.
And we also put the motor on
the back side of the necklace
so it was touching her skin.
So some pros of this were
that it was more robust,
and we thought about the
positioning a bit more,
but inside the circuit
is a bit messy,
and the battery is really heavy.
So the reason why we decided to
go with the nine volt battery
was because we wanted to make
sure she could still replace it
once we've given this to
her a little while later.
Because we were really tempted
to use a smaller battery,
but it'd be a lot harder
for her to replace,
and we really wanted to
think about maintainability.
So we're running out
of time, but we also
considered distance
and vibration.
And she approved of
the vibration strength,
and with the
distance we ended up
with 25 feet range, which
is good for the use cases
that we were considering.
And just wrapping up and
talking about some learning
and reflection that we
had with this project,
personally it was really
hard as a team for us
to narrow the scope
because Felicity
had a lot of great
project ideas,
and we also are all
software-oriented
so it was hard to learn
about the hardware.
Designing AT is really difficult
because we have to customize,
and it's hard to scale something
that you're customizing.
But working with
Felicity was amazing.
She was a really fantastic
and understanding client,
and we really learned a
lot through the process.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
ROB MILLER: So your
presentation actually looked
like a lot about exploring
[? the ?] products, right?
[INAUDIBLE]
I wonder if you could
say more about what you
learned about how [INAUDIBLE].
Some of it came out at
the end, [INAUDIBLE].
The sensitive areas,
but can you say
something about her
sense of comfort
while wearing
something like this?
BETH: So a few use cases-- so
we thought about this idea early
on actually in the
semester, but we moved away
from it-- but some use cases
that Felicity had initially
mentioned were like
during class-- she'd
take some classes, and
it's really hard for her
to know when someone has told
her it's her turn to speak,
and so this was
one use case there.
And also when
she's with friends,
and she's at a
concert or something,
and if she gets lost
from our friends,
this would be an easy way.
She doesn't always carry
her phone on her person,
and so if they text her,
she doesn't always know,
or if they're calling her.
And so this would be a quick
way to grab their attention.
One reason why we moved away
was we thought about security,
and if she went
to a coffee shop,
and she wanted them to use it,
how comfortable would people
feel when someone's
just walking up
to them with this random remote,
asking them to press a button
to ask for their attention.
So that's why we
felt like, socially,
it would be a really
awkward device.
And so we moved away from it.
ROB MILLER: Did you
ever actually try that?
Like go to a coffee
shop and [INAUDIBLE]?
BECCA: Well we did it
with-- we were just filming,
and we asked them if we
could like just videotape
our conversation while she
was ordering something,
and they were already really
uncomfortable, and so--
ROB MILLER: [INAUDIBLE].
BECCA: Well it
wasn't a-- oh, sorry.
SIMI: So she actually
told us that she
was uncomfortable with giving
this device to someone else.
I think part of one
discussion we had was
that she didn't want to have
to explain to someone else
why she's giving it to
them, because she already
has like trouble hearing
them and communicating
with them otherwise.
She wants every
piece of information
told right away so
that she doesn't
have to answer
questions, and she
was worried about the
questions that she
would have to answer if she
gives someone this device.
BECCA: And I guess the way we
mediated that was in the end,
the use cases we had for her
and the ones that she wants
is to use this with
friends and people
she's already familiar with.
GUEST SPEAKER: I have another
question. [INAUDIBLE].
Were there any kind of
pre-fabricated circuits
that we could have used?
I mean I love the fact
that you were able to-- it
was very instructive
[? building ?] the circuit.
But [INAUDIBLE].
Do you think that would
have been something that
could have served the purpose?
BECCA: Yeah.
So the receiver
itself is pre-bought.
So that's something we
used out of the box.
I think our functionalities
are a bit more unsophisticated
that we didn't have to turn
towards [INAUDIBLE] and more
expensive things.
The biggest, bulkiest
thing is the battery,
and that was just something
we decided to use,
because it was easily replaced.
PROFESSOR: OK.
With your team, I think over
the course of the semester,
you've gotten to
know Felicity better.
I'm interested in seeing what
the results are in evaluating
with them, and I think you've
done some strong work putting
together this prototype.
Well done.
All right.
Thanks.
BETH: Imagine
you're in your room;
you're sitting in
your wheelchair,
and you pull something
out of a drawer.
All of a sudden the drawer
starts falling on top of you.
Now because you have
limited mobility,
you can't just move
that drawer back up,
and because you aren't
able to yell for help,
you're pretty much helpless.
My name's Beth.
This is Tanya and Laura,
and this semester we
had the pleasure of working
with Margaret, our client.
She found herself in this very
situation, and because of that,
she wanted to have a better way
that she could call for help.
She lives in The Boston Home,
which is an assisted living
community for about 90
residents in Dorchester,
and she was diagnosed
with multiple sclerosis,
so she is bound to
wheelchair, as are all
of the residents of the home.
And like I said, the
goal of our project
is to design a system that
allows her to call for help.
Currently the system in
place in The Boston Home
is just inaccessible for a
large percentage of the time.
Currently, it's a button
that's attached to the wall,
and when you're pulling
the drawer open,
the button's
nowhere to be found.
So we did was
develop an iPad app--
we call it InstaAid--
and it allows
Margaret and many other
residents to call for help.
LAURA: So we frequently
visited The Boston Home
throughout the course
of the semester
to speak with both Margaret and
other staff members at the home
so that we could receive
feedback as we iterated
through several prototypes.
What you see here is
an iPad screenshot
of our first prototype.
Before we got to
the stage, we did
do some paper prototype
sketches as well
and then implemented
that on the iPad.
And in our first
iteration, our home screen
was too large buttons for
urgent and non-urgent requests.
Pressing the urgent
button results
in a video chat with a nurse
at the nurse's station,
and then pressing the
non-urgent button leads you
to the screenshot you see
in the middle with six
cookie-cutter requests that
residents commonly have
such as please give me water.
And pressing any
of these buttons
also leads that
resident to a video chat
with the nurse to specify more
information about the request.
Some feedback we received
from this iteration
was that we should replace
that colorful icons
that we previously had with
larger and more contrast icons,
so that it's easier for
residents to distinguish.
And we were also
advised to remove
the urgent and non-urgent
distinction for requests,
because each resident
at The Boston Home
might have different views
of what urgent means to them.
And finally, after
pressing one of the buttons
for common requests, rather than
being taken to a video chat,
we showed the resident
a screen that gave them
information about whether
their request has been received
by the nurse and whether it's
currently being addressed.
So with this in mind, we moved
on to our second iteration.
So you can see the
difference in icons
that we have here-- with
the black and white,
the higher contrast.
So we now have video
chat and send message
as two special icons that
we hadn't implemented yet.
But then the other
four buttons lead
to the request sent screen that
you see on the right-hand side.
And it also gives the
option to close the request.
And we also made a prototype
for the nurse in this iteration.
You can see here on
the left hand side
that the nurse currently has
two outstanding requests,
and then if you presses
the process request button,
it turns to green, and
then she can close it
once it's completely fulfilled.
Some feedback from
this iteration
is that we should introduce
a login system that
persists even when the app
closes so that residents
don't need to login every
time they open the app.
And at this point,
we still needed
to implement sending custom
text messages to the nurse
and the video chat.
TANYA: So before we went on
to test our final prototype
and go on to actually deploy
this at The Boston Home,
we decided to conduct
a couple of experiments
so that we knew what
we are dealing with.
So the first thing
we asked Margaret
was how often she was unable
to access the call light
system when she needed aid.
And she responded that it
was about 90% of the time.
And we also timed the amount of
time that it took for a nurse
to respond to her request by
pressing the call light button,
and that ended up being
approximately eight minutes
every time she did that.
And finally, because we're
using the iPad application,
and it depended on
her being able to send
this request to the
nurse's station,
we wanted to make sure that the
Wi-Fi network was robust enough
to handle this.
And we found that it was pretty
adequate-- that it covered most
of The Boston Home-- but there
were a couple of dead zones
and transitions might
have been an issue
if she was moving while
she was doing this.
So taking this all into account,
we made our final prototype
and were able to give this to
Margaret at The Boston Home.
So I'll just walk you through
a workflow of potentially
what a resident might do.
So they are led to
this home screen
with the high contrast buttons
and can press something
like bring water, in
which case they will go on
to the request sent button.
That request is then
sent to the nurses side.
It'll appear, and
they can go ahead
and say that they want to
process their request--
that they've received it.
And then that'll show up
on the resident's side,
saying request processed.
They can go ahead and close
the request if they want.
The nurse can also go ahead and
close the request on their side
as well once it's
been fulfilled.
Residents can also
send a text message.
So it's a custom
message that they
can send if they don't have
any of the preset ones.
So I need to take
my medications,
and they can tell the
nurse that they want that,
and that will show up as a
custom message on the nurse's
side as well.
And it proceeds from there.
So this wasn't shown
in this screencast,
but there's also a
video chat capability.
So this is us testing
it with Margaret.
She can simply press
the button, and then
it connects directly with the
iPad, so she's able to do that.
And what was great was when
we left it at The Boston Home
for a week, Don
actually was kind of
to make this Nurse's iPad mount.
So, as you can see, it's at the
nurse's station with a bunch
of the other devices there.
So the nurse typically needs a
computer, the call light system
itself, as well as a
desk space for paperwork.
So we put it right in
the center of the desk
so that they'll
be able to see it,
and it's always going to be on.
It's never going to turn off.
And so that's just a
closer up version of that.
So after this, we went back,
visited our experiments,
and tried to see what the
results of our week-long test
were.
And we found that
Margaret was successfully
able to send the
request via her iPad
and then receive
aid from the nurse
when she requested something.
So the iPad was actually
only inaccessible one time,
but during that one
time, the call light
was also an inaccessible,
so she had to find
a different way to request aid.
And we also found that the
response time is faster.
It was about three minutes.
And we are not
completely sure about how
that's going to work with
logistically, because we
believe that this might
be a faster response
time because it's a new
system, but we kind of
want to see how it pans
out in the long run.
And we also found that
there were no problems
with Wi-Fi connectivity
BETH: So from the
very beginning,
Margaret's vision was
for her to not just
be the only client-- for the
entirety of The Boston Home
to be the client.
So in this current
week, we've actually
been working to deploy this
system on more resident's
iPads, and we've already
received feedback,
and we're hoping to
incorporate that.
We've also received
the piece of feedback
that would be very
helpful to have
the location of the resident
when they send the request,
and that's something
that we would
propose as a feature project.
So ultimately, through
working on this project,
we want to reiterate that when
you design for one client,
that doesn't necessarily
scale for all.
We learned this.
We also learned that it's very
helpful to receive feedback
from many, many individuals,
not just your direct client.
So we worked with a lot of the
individuals in The Boston Home.
And finally, it was
difficult for us
to scope this project initially,
because there is so much
potential, but we
wanted to deliver
a product that was
very useful in the time
constraints of this class.
Ultimately, we'd really like to
thank our client Margaret, Don
Fredette, who many of
you have worked with.
We really appreciate
his help on our project
and all of The Boston Home
staff have been really
great at giving us feedback.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
GUEST SPEAKER:
I'm just wondering
what the variables that you find
really difficult to work with
were.
Things that were sort of
[INAUDIBLE] in an ideal world
have a little more
control over [INAUDIBLE]?
TANYA: I think one
of the main things
is definitely working
with the nurses.
So had started out with, of
course, talking to Margaret,
and then we found that
as much as we needed
to talk to Margaret,
we also needed
to talk to the nurse to
get her input on the UI,
and so on, and make sure that
she's comfortable with using
this system at her desk.
But one, it was kind of hard
for us to meet with her,
because every time
she was there,
she was always busy addressing
other residents' requests.
And secondly, she
actually ended up
leaving halfway through the
semester, so the feedback
that we had gotten from
her and was not necessarily
ported over to the next person
who's going to be there.
So working with
that and making sure
that whatever was going to
be used from the nurses side
would actually be used, even
though the residents would
be comfortable with the system,
it's not necessarily certain
that the nurse would
be able to do that.
So that was a bit of a hardship.
ROB MILLER: I'm
wondering how much--
you had a slide
about experiments,
and you had a slide about
[? results ?] [? from ?]
[? your ?] [? prototype. ?]
How much data was behind each
of those slides?
So when you were measuring eight
minutes as a response time,
how many trials was that?
[? When you were ?]
measuring her success
with the new system over
the course of the week.
How [? many tests ?]
[? did you actually ?]
[? get ?] [? there? ?]
BETH: So that's a
very good question,
and we're going to
answer honestly-- not
enough for a very good metric.
So honestly, we spent
an hour with her.
We did it maybe five times, and
that was kind of the average.
However, to have a really
good metric, we would--
ROB MILLER: Five times using
the old system you mean?
BETH: And five times
using the new system to
have some kind of a comparison.
But, of course, it's variable
throughout the course
of the week, and there are
many different variables
that would change that time.
So a more rigorous
amounts of metrics-- we
could write scripts
for our current system
to figure out how much
time is collapsing
between when the request is
sent and when it's processed.
And that's something
that we would
propose to do for future work.
ROB MILLER: She
had it for a week,
but it wasn't actually
logging the usage.
BETH: We have analyzed the
logging-- we haven't logged it,
and we haven't
analyzed it either.
PROFESSOR: Well, we'll Team
Beverly-Ann get set up.
I think it's
impressive what you've
done to build this
end-to-end system.
Can I ask a question-- it was
pretty early on in the semester
that you chose to go with
an all-software solution as
opposed to plugging in some
kind of wireless button
into the wall as
you might imagine
you might go in that direction.
Can you reflect a
little bit on that?
Do you think ultimately
it was the right decision?
Or when you made
that decision, did
you know what you're going down?
LAURA: Sure.
So all of us are
software people,
so that was partially an
initial reason for why
we wanted to go down this
route, but another reason
was just that we had
a lot of great ideas
for features that we wanted to
see in this app that wouldn't
be possible if we had chosen
to interface with the existing
system.
For example, this video
chat-- the concept
of sending custom
messages, maybe even being
able to receive feedback about
how far along in the process
their request is in
terms of being addressed.
So all of us are really happy
with the way it turned out.
Margaret was excited about
the concept of video chatting
and other residents that we've
tested this out on were also
happy with the ability to
send custom text messages,
so we think it worked out well.
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR: Let's get Team
Beverly-Ann to set up.
VINNIE: Hi everyone.
We're team Beverly-Ann.
I'm Vinnie.
SHRUTI: I'm Shruti.
ROBERT: I'm Robert.
VINNIE: And this is
our final presentation.
Our client's name
is Beverly-Ann.
So she has a wide
variety of interests.
She's a social worker
for the Department
of Children and Families.
She's learning how
to code using Scratch
and Arduino in her spare time.
She loves Wii Tennis.
She has a backyard
garden, and her main goal
is to maintain an active mind.
And she's also been
diagnosed for 11 years
with the
Charcot-Marie-Tooth, which
is a neurodegenerative disease
that affects the extremities.
SHRUTI: So everyone's experience
with CMT is different,
and in the case
of Beverly-Ann it
mainly manifests in sensory
failure and muscular failure
in her hands.
So if you can see the diagrams
over there-- on the left hand,
on the blue areas are
completely functional,
but the green areas are
experiencing muscular failure,
and they tend to curl in.
So they don't open, and thus
they're very useless to her.
On her right hand the sort of
gray areas are areas where she
can feel really well, but the
red areas are areas where she
cannot.
She feels numbness.
And so she has trouble
gripping things as a result,
because she loses
feeling in that hand.
And so as there is not just
a really consciously think
about actions she
performs, and this
includes like picking up
and holding on to objects,
typing, and walking down
stairwells with railings.
And you'll see in
the next few slides
we chose to focus on the
problem with her right hand.
ROBERT: So the assistive
technology challenge over here
is that because Beverly-Ann
is so worried that she's
going to drop something
whenever she's grabbing it,
she becomes less confident
in grabbing objects
with just one hand.
And here we are trying to
reinstall her confidence
in grabbing objects
with her right hand
by notifying her whenever
her grip is becoming loose.
And to design our
product, we put them
into three stages of prototypes.
And so, Shruti
talked about before,
we focused on the problem
with her right hand,
because she normally uses her
right hand to grab objects.
And very early on,
we decided that we
want to quantify
her grip pressure
and then notify her whenever
her grip is becoming loose.
So these are the early-stage
brainstorming ideas
we had, and we were
focusing on exploring
different choices of where to
put the pressure sensors as
well as the circuit boards.
So the left part shows that
we put in the pressure sensor
on the upper palm, whereas
the right part showing
another idea of
putting the pressure
sensor on her fingertips.
And then later on, we
followed the second idea.
So this is our
prototype stage one,
and it's a low-fidelity
nonfunctional prototype.
And we were exploring
multiple designs for this
[? look-a-like ?] prototype by
asking Beverly-Ann to try out
different versions and then
see which one feels the most
comfortable.
And then this upper
part are the pictures
that are for the minimalistic
design for the gloves.
That's the stage one prototype.
For the stage two
prototype, we were
mostly interested in
making a functional design,
so basically fulfilling
our goal of being
able to notify her-- one,
she gripping something
and it's slipping.
So we constructed a
circuit on a breadboard,
and we hooked it
up to an Arduino,
and then we coded--
we uploaded code
to the Arduino that would cause
a vibration motor to vibrate
whenever the sensors that are
also hooked up to the circuit
sense that you're
gripping the object,
and then it's released
past a certain threshold.
And we actually tested
this with Beverly-Ann,
and she really liked how
loud the vibration motor was
and how strong it was, and
she mentioned that it actually
helped her consciously
remember like, oh, I need
to re-grip and grip stronger.
And she actually also really
liked the material of the glove
that we used, and
she asked us not
to cut it like how we did
for our first prototype.
And is also pretty easy
to grip with the material
that we were using and
mostly we used this prototype
to test the range
of sensor values
that output when she grabbed
different types of objects,
for example a cup, or
a mug, or utensils,
and they actually turned out
to be around a similar range.
SHRUTI: So the main problem
with the previous prototype
was that it wasn't
portable because we have
to plug it into the computer.
So the final prototype which
is actually on my arm right now
is both functional and portable.
So the idea is that we
printed a circuit board
to do what our breadboard
was originally doing,
but that breadboard
was way too heavy.
So we got one custom
made, and that's here.
And then on the back, we
have an Arduino lily pad,
which is a lighter
version of an Arduino,
and it provides the code and
the power supply to the circuit.
We have sensors
attached to the gloves,
and then we have an arm band.
We discussed with
her a lot how she
wanted to carry
this device around,
and her main
constraint was that she
wanted it to be light,
but not on her upper arm
or too close to her
wrist-- somewhere
where it would be stable.
And so we chose to make an
arm band right around here,
so that it would be portable.
And the vibration motor
is sewn into the arm band,
so that if I were to
turn the switch on
to start it so that we
don't waste battery life,
and squeeze it, and then let
go, I can feel the vibration,
even though you can't
hear it, so that's
not disruptive to
other people around.
And the other thing
that we made sure to do
was that our power
supply is pretty light.
It's only one AAA
battery, and because it's
like a standard AAA battery,
she can replace it whenever
it goes out of battery.
So we don't have to worry
about prolonging its lifespan.
ROBERT: So for
experimentation, we mostly
did with our stage
two prototype, when
we met up with Beverly-Ann.
So we focused on two things.
The first thing is test
whether the prototype
is working as we
expected, in terms
of notifying Beverly-Ann
whenever her grip
pressure becomes loose, and
also to see whether it actually
decreases the time when
she drops the objects.
And also, the second
thing we focused on,
is to compare two cases-- one
is when she wears the glove.
And then the other
case when she does not
wear the glove in
terms of when would you
grips different types
of objects, including
a cup, phone, plate, and a fork.
And record different
holding times
in the case when she grabs
various objects, both
when she wears the glove and the
when does not wear the glove.
SHRUTI: So we took a lot of data
in the beginning, especially
when we had to make
our second prototype,
to figure out how
to sort of adjust
the code so that it would
work for her range of however
she would grip.
And so, if you
can see here, this
is like an example of the
kind of data we had to get.
A lot of it is just
voltage readings,
but the key voltage
values here are
what voltage do we see when she
drops-- or she's about to drop
the object that she's holding.
And what finger are we
reading this value from.
And so based on that, we
were able to figure out
how to tune the
code to accommodate
for all of her fingers.
We were also able to get time.
So the time in the
very last column
is approximately how
long she is holding it
before she either
unconsciously slips
it, or needs to put it down.
And we actually saw
just between not
having a prototype versus
having that second prototype,
a noticeable increase in the
amount of time, by about 50%.
Unfortunately since our
prototype only recently
became portable, we weren't
able to give it to her
for a long period of time.
And so we'd like to measure her
drop rate over about a week,
and then see, after she's
gone accustomed to the device,
whether the time it takes for
her to drop it is longer now,
instead of what it was before.
And that's what we'll be
doing over the next few weeks.
VINNIE: Here are a couple
reflections that we
had on the design process.
So one thing, especially,
is that simplicity is key.
I know this is something
very emphasized in the class,
and that's very true.
Another thing is that, in
order to design something
that your client can
use in real life,
it's very important to
have multiple prototypes
and to be able to deal with
any technical difficulties
that you have, that come
up with the process.
And, of course, you
always have to listen
to who you're working
with, because you're
a partner and a team, it's
not a customer/company sort
of relationship.
And some reflections on
6.811 PPAT-- we were all
really glad we took the class.
We kind of wish we had other
ways to educate ourselves
through about
disabilities beforehand,
but we're really glad this
class give us the opportunity
to explore that.
And I'm just going to leave
you guys with this one quote--
"If there's one thing
that PPAT has taught me,
it's that a disability
isn't a good enough reason
to stop doing anything."
Thanks, and we'll
take questions.
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR: Team Art can get
set up while we take questions.
GUEST SPEAKER: Is the
[INAUDIBLE] design--
is that something she'll have
to [INAUDIBLE] wearing and using
[? based ?] [? on her ?]
[? lifestyle ?] and where
the wires are out and there.
Are there any ideas
for casing it?
SHRUTI: So in terms of actually
being able to slip it on,
we found that that's
relatively easy.
And in terms of body
placement, we checked with her
to make sure that was OK.
The wires are honestly
our biggest problem
right now, because
they stick out,
and if they get caught
on to something,
that could be really
dangerous and could rip apart
the circuitry.
So along with giving
her the prototype
to see how it works for
her out in the field
for like the next
few weeks, we're
also going to talk about how
to cover all of the circuitry
so that it doesn't stick out.
And we have like cloth
and other materials
ready to like start sort of
making this more compact.
AUDIENCE: Have you thought
about using conductive thread?
SHRUTI: So we did.
The only issue was that the
board that we were using
required some components
that would require wires
anyways, and so, as
a result-- and plus,
actually connecting to the
glove would have definitely
required wires, because
there's like a gap in cloth
here that she wanted to have
a watch or bangles and such.
So we needed to
use wires anyways,
so we figured that
we might as well go
the whole way with wires.
And this way, we can
modify stuff easier.
[? VINNIE: The only thing ?]
[? placed ?]
[? in the lilypad ?] though is
that that's actually the one
she's working on herself.
Like she's [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Can I ask a question?
PROFESSOR: Yeah sure.
AUDIENCE: My last
question is actually--
so it seems like the
big thing for her
is that she needs
to remember that she
is trying to grip something.
And I wonder how much of
that reminder is simply
from wearing
something on her hand,
because it's kind of bulky, and
so it's kind of like, oh yeah,
I'm wearing this.
All right, I [INAUDIBLE].
And [? that's ?] [? it. ?]
[? Will you ?] [? have ?]
[? to vibrate ?] only
when she's about to drop
or if it's everything
that's [INAUDIBLE].
If it's vibrating the entire
time she's holding something,
is that enough of a reminder
to prevent her from dropping?
VINNIE: So I'm not
really sure, because when
we were talking to her, and
she was focusing on it--
so when she had the
glove, we ended up
having to just ask her questions
so her mind would be distracted
off of it.
So I think if it's a
continuous vibration,
she might get
habituated to it and not
recognize it as something
that she has to respond to.
SHRUTI: That was that was our
main concern-- that if we just
had some sort of static device,
that she would get used to it,
and then start ignoring it.
But when we did
the data analysis,
we made sure that as soon
as her grip starts to slip--
and we worked on this
really carefully with her--
it would buzz immediately.
And she really felt
that it notified her
as soon as she was in any
danger of dropping something.
So she was like,
this is much better
than having some sort
of consistent reminder.
ROBERT: Also, I feel like it's
not really about her forgot
about she is
grabbing something--
she knows she's
grabbing something,
but it's just
gradually, over time,
she's not sure how much
force she is exerting,
because she cannot
feel her fingers.
So because of that, she
generally loses confidence
in grabbing things, just
because of the fear of she
might drop it.
So it's really more
about telling her
that you won't drop
it, and just be
confident with grabbing things.
And then whenever you are about
to drop it, we will notify you.
So having that
confidence really puts it
back into a normal
condition-- we're
giving her the capability of
grabbing things with one hand.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Thank you very much.
RACHEL: Hi everyone.
I'm Rachel.
This is Jessica, and
this is Stephanie.
We're Team Art, and
we're here to talk to you
about the vertical screw lift
that we spent this semester
designing and building.
First we'd like you
to meet Art, who's
actually right over there.
We are really happy he
was able to come today.
He is an avid
hacker, rock climber,
and member of his
community, which
is the town of Billerica,
Massachusetts, where
he lives with his girlfriend.
He is a very active,
gets himself around,
is very independent,
and wanted to be
able to take
advantage-- he works
a lot with mechanical
tools, and he
wanted to be able to get in
and out of his wheelchair
onto the floor.
He's in a chair because he has
T5 Asia B Paraplegia, and that
means he has no motor
function and limited
sensory function below the
legs-- below the waist, sorry.
He has a hacker space at the
Artisan's Asylum in Somerville,
and this is where we spent most
of our time meeting with him.
So, as I just said, our
goal was to design a lift
to help Art move up
and down from the floor
in multiple settings.
So the idea was he would be
able to use it at his home,
or at the Artisan's
Asylum, or maybe
bring it into his car to take
it wherever he might be going.
And we had a couple
of design goals
with this-- we wanted a
clearance height of four inches
or less.
We wanted it to be able to lift
Art in less than 45 seconds,
because existing
devices like pull swings
tend to be very slow.
And we wanted it to weigh
less than 20 pounds which
is what his girlfriend
is capable of lifting,
but lift up to 300.
The bottom line though, really
the most important thing
in all of this, was that
we wanted our design
to be portable, and we
wanted it to be safe to use.
And with a mechanical
device like this,
this is surprisingly
difficult to accomplish.
So I wanted to walk you all
through the sorts of designs
we were considering
while we were doing this.
The first thing we
talked about as a team
was this scissor lift design,
which is used quite frequently
in industrial settings.
It's what you might see on one
of those like cherry picker
things that the
telephone guy uses.
But they're very complicated
pieces of machinery, actually,
and the actuators and hinges
are very expensive for them.
So we decided this
is not a good option.
Next we thought about a
sort of out-there solution--
the idea of using
a lifting cushion.
But these, we realized
after talking to Art,
would present us with
stability problems--
if we wanted variable
height, which
we do he might want to
transfer to a 12-inch surface
or an eight-inch surface,
or maybe to something
higher than his chair even.
If it was only
partially inflated,
transferring on and
off of the cushions
would be a huge problem.
So we started talking about
using this tripod design, which
would be very stable, and had
fewer parts than the scissor
jack, we thought.
But the more we talked
about it, the more
we realized that the pulley
that we had designed,
like right here-- that
pulls the seat up and down
wasn't going to provide a safety
for Art when the motor was off.
So the seat would be in
danger of sliding up and down.
And so we'd have to install some
sort of manual break or chain
mechanism, and we
thought long and hard
about how to implement
this and decided
we weren't sure how to do it,
so we needed another idea.
And those of you who were
able to join us last time
will remember that we brought
in this cute little prototype
about this big that
had a screw built
into it, which basically-- you
turn the screw and the seat
goes up or the seat goes down.
And the thing that's
really wonderful
that this is that even
when the motor's off,
the seat doesn't move
vertically at all.
It's quite stationary.
It's very stationary,
even on our big design.
So we can go to the next slide.
STEPHANIE: So we
will be showing you
our product and our functions.
So currently what
Rachel is doing
is connecting a few 24-volt
batteries through Anderson
plugs to our motor,
which was provided by Don
Fredette of The Boston Home.
It's been critically useful.
So as you can see, because
that's a bi-directional switch,
we have the capability
of having the motors turn
to different directions,
so we can essentially
move the seat up-- Yes, thanks.
As you can see, it
functions perfectly fine.
So what exactly is this
contraption made of?
Well, the frame is
actually made up
of a bunch of
80-20 aluminum rods
that we actually scrounged
from an abandoned
laser in the physics lab.
So the entire frame
would probably
cost you $200 to maybe $400
if we purchased directly
from the 80-20 site, so
we got really lucky there.
The lifting mechanism
is actually--
it's essentially a Acme rod
that we-- a threaded Acme rod
that we purchased ourselves.
And this is the life-size
version of the tiny screw
that you guys saw in the
previous balsa wood tiny model.
And we were able to obtain that
motor that's turning the Acme
rod and these batteries
from again Don
Fredette from The Boston Home.
The seat is made of
aluminum, and it was actually
water jetted by someone from
the course three department.
It weighs approximately
8 to 10 pounds,
so it bears a decent
bulk of the weight.
And there is a lot of connective
hardware in our device.
To actually interface the
motor with the Acme rob,
we had to purchase a few
sprockets and a chain
in order to actually
have the motor actuate
the spinning motion
of the rod itself.
And we had to purchase several
flanges, flange bearings,
and thrust bearings in
order to reduce friction
between the Acme rod
and the 80-20 frame
itself, as well as
actually connect
the Acme rod to the seat.
So as Rachel mentioned
before, our desired features
involve preferably
moving Art up and down
about 22 to 24 inches
in less than 45 seconds.
We would like a clearance
distance of four inches,
and we wanted the device to
weigh less than 20 pounds.
Currently, our device
lifts and lowers
a complete length in
approximately 30 seconds,
so we definitely met
the first feature.
We also met the second
feature in the sense
that we have a clearance
distance of four inches.
Unfortunately, we
were unable to make
this apparatus weigh
less 15 pounds,
because it weighs 30 pounds.
And that can be attributed
to the really, really
heavy aluminum frames.
And currently, it
actually does not
lift weight, because
the motor does not
provide enough torque
to actually lift
a significant amount of weight.
JESSICA: So we got pretty
close with this design,
but there are still a
few improvements that we
would have liked to make.
First and foremost, we
need higher torque motor.
Our current motor does
not have enough torque
to actually lift
weight and that's
the primary function
of our device,
so if we can't perform
that, it's a problem.
We would also like to reduce
the weight of this contraption,
because it is a little
heavier than we'd like.
So lighter and thinner
parts would be optimal.
Another issue is portability.
That was one of our
original design goals
and we haven't quite
gotten there yet.
Our current idea
would be to add wheels
to the back end
of it and a handle
so that you could
tilt and pull back.
And safety-- the
device is pretty safe,
except for the loose
chain that's open here,
so we would like to
be able to cover that.
And some of the
things that we've
learned through this project
are that parts are expensive.
Software is not so expensive.
Parts are expensive.
Understanding and designing for
your user is very important,
but you also have to keep in
mind safety, and feasibility,
and it can be
pretty complicated.
Iteration, therefore, is key.
That is one of the most
important things you can do.
And sadly, with our limited time
frame, and our large device,
it was hard to iterate
as much as we wanted.
Like I said, the most valuable
resource there, of course,
would be time, since we didn't
have enough time to iterate
as much as we'd like.
Reaching out to others
for assistance--
that's super important.
We received a lot
of help from Art
from the Department
of Material Science.
And we received a
lot of help from Don,
who gave us a lot
of parts, and who
helped us connect
all of this together.
And from the PPAT
staff in general.
And so with that, we'd
like to thank you guys
and open the floor to questions.
[APPLAUSE]
ROB MILLER: I wonder if you
could talk a bit about-- I know
you said that it can't
actually lift anyone,
but did Art try to get on it?
So what is the process
like for getting yourself
situated on that platform?
And is it stable enough to
be [? in that ?] [? state ?]
without falling
over [INAUDIBLE]?
STEPHANIE: So it's definitely
based on Rachel just
standing on the apparatus
and jumping on it--
it's definitely stable in terms
of actually holding up weight.
But the issue is--
RACHEL: I should add though--
this is a new development.
That was not true
until Sunday, when
Art helped us [? machine ?]
apart to keep the seat stable.
We had all of this working,
except the [? seat ?] was
wobbly for the
longest time, and we
were concerned about this as
a design feature, obviously.
We actually didn't get to
the point of having tried it,
but we'd like to do that
[INAUDIBLE] questions?
GUEST SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHTER]
STEPHANIE: Ideally
though, there should
be no issue with Art
transferring into and out
of the chair, because this
would be positioned right
next to his wheelchair,
so that he would have
to do a slide over
onto the chair,
once it's set at
the ideal height.
ROB MILLER: But if
you're on the floor--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ROB MILLER: [INAUDIBLE] lift
himself up and [INAUDIBLE].
RACHEL: Yeah.
So the clearance of four inches
was a design goal given by Art.
Four inches is the
maximum distance
that he's comfortably
able to move vertically
to a different surface.
JESSICA: And so we were trying
to counter that with the design
[? itself. ?]
GUEST SPEAKER: So that frame
that's parallel to the chair,
and running through [INAUDIBLE]
come up to seat height,
and then you would [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Any questions?
AUDIENCE: What do you think
are the trade-offs of making
it lighter and the
safety [? constraints? ?]
if it's lighter, wouldn't
it be easier to tip over?
Have you guys thought about
what happens if it falls over.
RACHEL: So I guess I should
talk into the microphone.
Basically, no,
because the center
of mass of this
contraption is always
going to be over the center
of the center of the frame,
and with a user on it,
or transferring onto it,
there's always going to be
weight over the support base.
In terms of making
it lighter, we
wouldn't be looking probably
to replace the entire frame.
We might make it out of
like a smaller 80-20.
i feel like that
was a possibility.
But the biggest thing we
could do to reduce weight
is to reduce the
thickness of the seat.
Half inch aluminum holds
up like 1,000 pounds,
and that's just unnecessary.
It's just happened to be
what we had lying around.
It was what we didn't
have to pay for.
And if we had a lot of time, we
would probably go and mill out
some shapes in the bottom to
optimize thickness where it was
necessary and cut out extra
weight where it wasn't.
The other reason that
it's heavy in general
is just that we ended up
finding that lighter components,
like components that weren't
made for heavy-duty usage
we're going to
stand up to the wear
and tear we expected
this device to see.
We actually had a
second prototype
that never made it in here,
because it was terrible.
We bought cheap components, and
they were lighter components,
and they didn't work
at the rotations.
That rod right now is
turning at 400 RPM,
and so it has to be
able to spin really
smoothly and without bending.
And so any material
that's tool-grade steel
doesn't work and et
cetera, et cetera.
PROFESSOR: All right.
In the interest of
time, we should move on,
but thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
Can we get Team Paul to set up?
YI: So we're Team Paul.
My name is Yi.
LEXIE: I'm Lexie.
BRADY: And I'm Brady
YI: And we are design
a coffee crane.
Which we'll let you know.
So first we just want
to quickly review.
So our client is Paul.
He has been an amputee
for over 30 years,
so he uses these forearm
crutches to help him.
And then because he had
an injury with his hip,
[INAUDIBLE] so he's been kind
of regaining his strength.
And he's doing
physical therapy now,
so he's mostly staying home.
So our client's not
going to be around.
So we're designing
this for the home.
So the problem
statement is we want
to design a device
or a mechanism that
allows Paul to carry at
least one full cup of coffee
around his house without
spilling of without gripping
onto the cup like is, which
is how he carries it before.
And the success metrics that
we had were current status--
well, I guess, the
previous status--
is that coffee cup can only
be filled to one third full.
So in the morning, he can
only fill it up to one third,
walk to the sofa, and then
sit down, and then drink
the one third cup of coffee
and then go back to get more.
And he had to
claw-grip on the cup.
So because he's using
crutches, that sometimes
can be turbulent-- so even
if it's only one third full,
it can still spill on his hand.
And so when we were
coming up with goals,
we two goals-- the livable
goals and the ambitious goal.
So we wanted to
design something that
doesn't spill when
it's 2/3 full,
and there's no need
to hold on to the cup
like he does now,
where it's clawing.
And then hopefully it can
be removable with 20 seconds
on and off time.
And then Paul gives us a
rating of six out of 10,
and it works for
one of his mugs.
Because that's one
of the main things
Paul wants is he wants to use
his mugs, instead of maybe
a thermal or something.
An ambitious goal is no spill
with coffee cup 3/4 full,
and no need to hold it.
And then removable
within 10 seconds,
and then Paul rates
it eight out of 10,
and it works for
all of his mugs.
And then just some of
our early prototypes.
So we were thinking
of maybe if we just
cover the cup with one of these,
which works really well-- it
will not spill.
And then just maybe put it
in one of the stage holders,
and then just put the stage
holder on his crutches.
And because his mug didn't fit
in that-- that's too small--
we were thinking of
another kind of cover,
which is the flexiCover.
So it takes actually a
lot of strength to put on,
and you have to stretch it.
And then we were
thinking, well, maybe
we can use some sort of
gyroscopic cup holder
idea, which allows it to swing.
And then this works horrible,
and there's spilling
even when you put the cup in.
And then we thinking
this kind of clamp
to clamp onto his crutches,
which we have here.
And Paul actually destroyed
it, because it's too weak.
He broke this things
when we tested it.
And then, after all
those iterations
and looking for
the right products,
we have a final prototype.
LEXIE: So our final
prototype-- one of the main
we-- products that we
found was the Spill Not.
And basically it's a product
that if you put a coffee
mug on it, you can put it
at any angle basically,
and it won't spill the contents.
And this has to do
with the forces--
as you move this way--
counteract the other forces.
So, magic.
[LAUGHTER]
But this definitely works
with basically any mug
that you could put in
here, and it definitely
works with all of Paul's
mugs, and probably any he
would get in the future.
And it definitely is no spill.
The only time it would spill
is if it hit something or gets
jarred in any way.
So we decided to put it on a
rod far away from his crutch
so it wouldn't actually
hit into his crutch,
and basically just
put a hook on the end
so that he could easily
connect it onto the rod.
And then it would be easy
to just slip on and off.
And we needed a stronger
clamp, obviously.
This is not actually the
one we ended up using.
I don't have a picture of it.
We got clamps from Don
Fredette, and basically it's
a clamp that he would
leave on there permanently,
and he's really OK with that.
He actually really
likes that it's there
and it's very solidly
on his crutch.
And then he can just attach
this rod to the clamp then.
And then we added
this handle on it
to make it even
easier to put on.
And this is the product
on Paul's crutch.
It doesn't have the
handle on it yet.
This picture was taken
before we put in on.
So some of the
assumptions that we
made while making
this final prototype
were that when he's putting
the Spill Not on and off,
he would be able
to remain standing,
and he wouldn't spill anything.
And that basically he would
be able to move around
his apartment and
maneuver in there.
And so when we went to
experiment with this,
we actually were using the
weaker clamp at the time,
so we basically couldn't test
with the coffee cup in it,
but we were able to test
different rod lengths.
So there's eight-inch, and
then we also tested a 12-inch,
and then we tested where
he was able to hold it
out this way with his
crutch, and this way,
and then this way basically.
And we found that straight
ahead was the best orientation,
because it didn't
knock into the wall
and all the other ones
did, with the eight-inch.
So this is a video of
Paul putting the clamp on.
And as you can see, it
doesn't take very much time,
because the clamp
is already on there,
and he's just
putting the rod on.
And then he puts the
Spill Not on top of it.
And he can maneuver with it.
And it just kind of
hanging out there.
And he's able to maneuver.
That's his cat.
He's able to maneuver around
his apartment fairly easily.
BRADY: So as you can see
from our success metrics,
we had Paul test
out the prototype.
We left it with them for a week.
Asked for his feedback, and he
gave us very, very enthusiastic
feedback.
He loves it.
He rates it 10 out of 10.
It was actually really nice to
see when we walked in the door
when we met with them that
he had the clamp still
on from when we'd given
it to him last week.
He said he hadn't taken it off.
So that was really nice.
And he said he's been
walking around his apartment
with full cups of coffee.
He hasn't spilled anything
yet, so he's really
really happy about that.
Obviously he doesn't need
to hold the coffee cup,
because it's out
on the Spill Not.
So that was another one of our
ambitious goals that we met.
The one part that
we didn't quite meet
is it does take a little bit
longer to put on and take off,
because it is that rotating
motion putting on and taking
out the extension as opposed
to, say, a quick release
clamp or something like that.
But that was a trade-off we were
willing to make because it's
definitely more sturdy.
Like we said, he
destroyed our other clamp,
because he's got really,
really good grip strength.
And like we said, it works
for all of Paul's mugs.
So that part's fantastic.
All right so what did we
learn through all this?
Nothing is as simple
as it first appears.
You kind of
underestimate the task
when you think, oh, I just
need to have him walk around
his apartment with a
full cup of coffee--
how hard can that possibly be?
But it turns out, it was
actually really, really
difficult, and if it hadn't
been for the Spill Not,
we probably wouldn't have been
able to accomplish the goal
that we had set for ourselves,
but that Spill Not was
definitely a lifesaver.
Fail fast and iterate
until success.
Like we said, the covers
probably would've worked OK,
but they're really hard to put
on and take off, so from then
that kind of sparked
the rest of our ideas.
And then with the Spill
Not, we thought maybe
he could just hang it off
the handle of his crutch
but that doesn't really
occur to you-- well
what happens if it
bumps into his crutch,
and all of a sudden it
start's spilling everywhere?
So fail fast and
iterate from there.
And finally, keep the
end user involved.
Paul met with us
pretty much every week.
He was always available,
and we definitely
came up with
something in the end
that he's very, very happy with.
And from Paul we learned to be
grateful for the small things,
such as being able to
carry a full cup of coffee.
And his favorite quote
and the thing and he
said literally every
time we visited
was 'You guys are
doing wonderful stuff.
This is great.
So keep it up."
All right.
That's it.
[APPLAUSE]
BRADY: Yes?
ROB MILLER: So what
you ended up with still
has three parts to it right?
BRADY: Yes.
ROB MILLER: There's the
bar; there's the Spill Not,
and [? the coffee ?] [? cup. ?]
Did you explore trying to cut
that down to two?
Certainly, you need the cup
to be able to [INAUDIBLE]?
BRADY: You mean as in from here
and eliminate the hook portion?
LEXIE: Well when you're spending
it on, it would kind of-- I
mean you could do
it, but I think
that it was a little bit hectic
if you wanted to spin it on,
it would kind of flip
the Spill Not around.
BRADY: Plus the
other part is how
Paul uses it is once
he's out of the kitchen
and into his living room,
the table is actually
at just the right
height where he
can remain standing and
gently set the Spill not.
Onto the table and unhook
it from his crutch.
So then he doesn't
run the risk of-- he
would you have to
remain standing
and try and unscrew it with
the cup still on the Spill Not.
ROB MILLER: It helps
with the delivery.
BRADY: It helps with
the delivery time
onto the-- exactly.
[? ROB MILLER: The ?] other part
of that would be that if you
could attach the clamp to the
rod, but is difficult for him--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
BRADY: Finding a clamp
that worked really well
and then finding the correct
length rod to keep it out,
away from the crutch was
kind of an iterative process.
Like I said, we tried
out the 12-inch,
we tried out the eight-inch.
and.
Other thing is he
really liked the idea
of keeping it on
there permanently,
at least the clamp.
And if there would have been
a quick release clamp that
worked very well, we
probably would have looked
into that a little bit further.
But the clamp that he
liked the best thing
and that definitely
worked the best
is the one that was
on there permanently.
So it made more sense to just
be able to unscrew the rod.
AUDIENCE: Could I
suggest that maybe you
look into getting
him a crutch you
would attach this to that
he only uses in the house?
BRADY: So Paul's crutches
are actually custom.
AUDIENCE: Are they
super expensive?
BRADY: Yeah.
The previous group mentioned
like $200 to $400 for aluminum,
we'd be easily double
that max price.
ROB MILLER: [INAUDIBLE]
bend you over for any kind
of adaptable gear.
AUDIENCE: What?
ROB MILLER: It's called
any time you say,
oh, adaptable equipment.
Drop your drawers and bend
over, because there's something
you really don't like.
GUEST SPEAKER: I'm
wondering if we
can get t-shirts with that "Fail
fast, iterate until success."
[LAUGHTER]
BRADY: The MIT motto right?
PROFESSOR: In the interest
of time, thank you very much.
BRADY: Thanks.
KELLY: Hi guys!
I'm Kelly
EDDY: I'm Eddy.
EUNICE: I'm Eunice
KELLY: And we're here to talk
to you guys about script speak.
So our client this
semester was Barbara,
who was a former teacher who now
lives at the Leonard Florence
Center.
Barbara, over a
year ago, found out
that she was diagnosed with
Primary Lateral Sclerosis,
which is a neurodegenerative
disease, which
results in muscle weakness.
As a result, speaking
for her now is very hard,
and her speaking has gotten more
unclear as time has progressed.
Because of her
first speech, she's
faced several challenges
in different sorts
of environments.
When it comes to
group environments,
it can be very hard for
people to understand her,
because often they're
very, very noisy.
She also trouble
speaking to people
who don't understand
how her speech
functions, such as
non-native English speakers,
or a taxi drivers-- people who
just don't have correspondence
with her.
She's also found that in
virtual environments, It's.
Also very difficult for
her to talk to people.
So through phone or video chat.
I'm
Currently she's tried out two
solutions besides speaking,
and one of them was
called Proloque4Text.
This is an assistive
text to voice app,
and she found a very
unintuitive to use,
because technology
is not her forte.
And she also try
using something called
a BoogieBoard, which is a
more physical board that she
can use instead.
And through this,
she found that it
was nice because
she could write,
but also kind of inconvenient,
because she would have
to write out everything
she wanted to say,
and she couldn't
save it anywhere.
And so both of these solutions
we're lacking something.
And knowing that she
was technologically not
very equipped, we
knew that had to be
simple to fix her problem.
And so we decided to
create ScriptSpeak.
ScriptSpeak is a text to voice
app, whose main purpose is
to be as simple to
use as possible,
as well as customizable, so the
user can enter in any phrases
they want.
And ultimately, it should
expanded the environment
in which she can speak.
EDDY: So our success
metrics are here.
Our livable goals
is what I'm mainly
cover, which is we wanted
her to be able to attempt
to speak-- one of
the main reasons
is you use it or lose it, right?
So she continues to
try and use her speech,
but even over the
course of this class,
we have seen a significant
decrease in her ability
to pronounce certain syllables.
So we want to be able to
try, but if she ends up
not being able to speak, we
want to be able to either type
out the phrase, or if she's
already spoken that phrase,
she can find it in her
history or in her favorites
within five clicks.
We want to basically have
her increase the efficiency
of her speech by lowering her
response time by about 20%
overall.
So basically, an amortized
cost over how many times
she reuses phrases, as opposed
to her current method, which
she has to type every
phrase, whenever
she's going to speak it.
So she can't really reuse
or use the components
that are available, even
though the features are there.
It's just very
complicated for her.
And larger, noisier environments
from five to 10 people.
So right now she's really
OK with speaking to you
and using her current
apps when it's
one-to-one or one-to-three,
especially for our meetings.
But in other
settings, she wasn't
unable to use her apps
because the iPhone is too low.
And the iPad app she hadn't used
for an extended period of time,
so she was very
uncomfortable using it.
So we wanted to give
her a solution she can
use in both of those settings.
So we started prototyping
with her main point being
keep it simple.
The simpler the better.
So we started off-- we gave
her this paper prototype where
we had her test.
And right from the
start, we found out
that we found that
most of the common UI
functionality that
we're all used
to with apps in the
app store don't really
seem intuitive to her.
So swiping to delete, and a few
other of these characteristics
were not something
she would use.
So we stripped that
down, and we went
back to how UIs are
more intuitive in terms
of you see, and you click on
it, and that's what you get.
So we see here the star
for favoriting and so on.
Then we created our second
prototype really quickly,
because we wanted to get
something in her hand
with App Inventor.
So we built basically an app
that she could click the text
and it would like play, and
she can add text and store that
into her history.
So that was our
initial prototype.
Then we started
having the iOS app.
So we don't want to have no
interaction until too late.
So we started of-- we
had her history page
and her favorites page
right from the start.
But we needed to
update a few things
so we could have the stars be
on and off as she would like it.
And then we connected both.
So whatever she did
on the history page,
it was reflected on
the favorites page
if it was necessary.
And then after we finished
this, we brought it to her,
and we got a piece of
feedback we didn't expect,
which is that she
wanted it to connect
between her iPhone and her iPad.
Initially, she said
that her iPhone
was too low-- the
volume was too low,
so she really couldn't use
it in most environments,
but then she told
us that if she's
going to be a smaller setting,
she's in her phone with her,
because it's less heavy.
So we needed to
connect both of them.
So we just connected
the apps through Parse,
and we're going to
deliver that to her.
So the functionality
is the same.
It's just now whatever
she types in in one
will be reflected in the other.
So we'll have a demo for you.
KELLY: Now we're
going to show you
guys a demo using the simulator.
However, the text-to-speech
doesn't actually
play on a laptop, so we will
play it for you on our iPad.
But as you can see,
we have the app
working on both the
phone and the iPad,
so it's customizable for both.
EDDY: Trying to
find your screen.
KELLY: Pull it that way.
EDDY: This way?
Seems like the simulator
cannot be dragged.
KELLY: It can't be dragged over.
EDDY: It cannot be dragged over.
KELLY: Can you switch it?
No, you can switch
the-- [INAUDIBLE].
I don't remember [? that. ?]
EDDY: In any event, we do have--
KELLY: Wait [INAUDIBLE]
should be moving.
AUDIENCE: Go in
System Preferences.
EDDY: Oh, in System Preferences?
So in any event, we do have
the app loaded onto our iPad.
So we added the feature
that she can compose
a sentence with
previously said text,
and then she can
play it in the end.
So can store her
name, and whenever
she has to type in her name,
it's always there for her.
We also added that she
can delete her messages,
and she can go to her
history, and in her history
she can favorite the items.
And then if she
deletes these items--
SYNTHETIC SPEECH:
This is awesome.
EDDY: So she can play it.
A little plug-in there.
And if she delete
these from her--
SYNTHETIC SPEECH:
This is awesome.
EDDY: I'm sorry.
If she deletes these
from her favorites,
it reflects in her history.
And since we also delete
it from the history,
it no longer shows up.
We have another,
more intensive--
technical difficulties.
KELLY: Sorry, the simulator's
too big for that screen,
so we just have to go.
EDDY (WHISPERING): So
we'll just continue on.
It's fine we'll
just continue on.
it'll be fine.
KELLY (WHISPERING): I
don't know how to use this.
EDDY: All right.
KELLY: Present,
present, present.
EDDY: So that's most
of the functionality.
And now it's connected as well.
And she's been using
this past week.
A week and a half.
EUNICE: So we did a couple
experiments with her
to see how well our app worked
compared to all the other ways.
So we asked her to say
a short phrase first.
So just to say "Hi, my name is
Barbara" four different ways.
First by speaking, and then
writing on the BoogieBoard,
and then ScriptSpeak, and
then also her app Proloque.
As you can see, the
second time-- the orange
is when she writes the
phrase the very first time,
and then she saves
it in the app.
And then when she
closes the app and then
access it the second time,
ScriptSpeak is a lot faster.
The first time takes
a while, because this
was on her iPad, which is new.
So the auto correct
wasn't trained enough
with what she usually says.
So another thing
that we also measured
was the number of
clicks that it takes.
Also for ScriptSpeak, it
takes a lot fewer clicks.
As you can see here.
And also for Proloque,
the other app,
it is very inconsistent, because
it's very confusing for her.
So even though she saved
it, she couldn't find it,
so she had to end up
typing it again, which
is why it takes so many clicks.
This is a video of
her using Proloque.
Play it.
We don't have time
for the video.
EDDY: We can play it.
KELLY: Oh my gosh.
OK, we can move on then.
EDDY: So basically
in the video, you
see that she doesn't feel
comfortable with Proloque.
So we asked her to
repeat the phrase,
and she has to type out
the entire phrase again,
because she doesn't
know where it's stored.
Whereas, in our
application, she was
able to go to the other screen,
and immediately just find
in her history, and then
she favorited it after that,
and she had it as well.
So she was able to play
from the history page
without any real time.
It was like a three,
four second time
to reply, whereas
the other [INAUDIBLE]
was just as when she typed it.
EUNICE: And then we asked
her to repeat the experiment,
this time with a longer phrase.
And as you can see, the second
time it was a lot shorter.
With Proloque, it seems
like the second time is also
a lot shorter, but actually
it didn't really work,
so she clicked
it, and the phrase
was entered into her
text like multiple times,
and she was very
confused about it.
So actually, even those it
was fast, it didn't work well.
And as for the number of clicks,
similarly, it was fewer clicks,
but it didn't work.
So that didn't
accomplish the goal.
This is the amount
of time she used it.
So we left the app with
her over a weekend.
And she used-- this
is the information
we got from her iPad.
She used this phrase
twice, three times--
so she was actually
using this app to speak.
And she also used
on her phone more,
but we couldn't get
the data for that.
PROFESSOR: I think we're going
to stop here, just so that we
have time for questions.
Thanks very much.
[APPLAUSE]
Questions?
GUEST SPEAKER: I know
that in the beginning,
you were going with a different
direction with Barbara, right?
For using kind of a [? door ?]
automation, something.
Was it really difficult
to kind of switch gears
and go in another
direction when you
realized the first goal
wouldn't be achievable.
KELLY: Yeah, that was
probably the hardest thing
we had to deal
with all semester,
because when we finally chose
our idea to go with software
and develop and app, with
lost around a month's time.
So we had to really
cram it all in,
but it basically made us
realize that early on we
got to learn how to fail fast.
And so you can go with an idea,
but only until you realize
that's it's not possible.
And you shouldn't just
hold on to one thing,
because you think that that's
the only idea that she wants.
And so it's really important
to always communicate
with your client and throw out
any ideas you have as well,
because you're also
part of the solution,
and you have as much
say in it as they do.
And you can bounce
ideas of each other
and come up with
something really awesome.
EDDY: Another part
of that is that part
of what we have here
in our lessons learned
is we came up with an
idea of the ScriptSpeak
that we were never
asked for initially.
She really didn't think of
it as a possible solution.
She wanted home automation,
and we focused on that,
until we found
out by regulations
that we would have
too short of a time
to actually make a difference.
So we were able to make an
idea and converse with her
about something that she
didn't particularly want.
And then the moment we came up
with that idea, she was like,
oh, I love that.
Do that.
Forget the door.
So it was a hard
process, but we ended up
liking the project we had.
And we're all CS majors,
so it was definitely
our home-field advantage.
GUEST SPEAKER: So was it
something that you just
intuitively knew would help her?
KELLY: So she actually
mentioned many times
that she would like an app that
would help her speak better,
because it's the most difficult
problem she deals with.
She just didn't know that it
was possible to create something
that could fix it.
And so we realized that
hey, we're CS majors.
We can definitely
do this for you.
And she was amazed the see
that it was actually possible.
PROFESSOR: Other
questions or comments?
OK.
I think we're at the time today.
Thank you very
much Team Barbara.
[APPLAUSE]
Well, down there
today everybody.
Thanks for coming out for these
three hours of presentations.
We will have a class selection
next Wednesday at one o'clock,
and then the showcase is from
3:00 to 5:00 next Wednesday.
Thanks very much.